RIGHT WELL- GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY THANK YOU
FOR. JOINING US- HERE AND WANT
TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
ASSEMBLY- COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON WILDFIRE IMPACTS ON
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IT WAS
MY FIRST HEARING AS CHAIR OF
THIS. THIS IS A. UGH COMMITTEE
AND SO I WANTED EXTEND MY-
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO SPEAKER
RENDON FOR I. IN TRUSTING ME.
OR IF INTERESTED BI STEWARDSHIP
OF THIS COME- ANY POINT ISSUES
THAT WE HAD- TO FOR- COMMITTEE
CHAIR I ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOON TO
SENATE WHO EGGMAN. WHO
UNFORTUNATELY AT THE LAST
MINUTE WAS NOT UNABLE TO BE
HERE WITH US THIS AFTERNOON.
BUT I WANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR
SOLID LEADERSHIP- NOT ONLY AS
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE- BUT
THROUGHOUT HER TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND FOR A
THOUGHTFUL MENTORSHIP. TO ME
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS. AND TO
THE MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE
ESPECIALLY VICE. MISTER MATHIS
WHO IS HERE WITH US THIS
AFTERNOON I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM AND ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE. I AND
FINALLY TO OUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT VICTOR FRANKEL ****
ARE HI COMMITTEE SECRETARY MONA
WOULD- AND THE ASSEMBLY- ARE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT STAFF-
SPENCER JONES OUR CHIEF OF
STAFF- IN PARTICULAR WHO HAVE-
WHO HAVE DUG IN OVER THE PAST.
TWO MONTHS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PREPARED FOR THE UPCOMING
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. SO WE AS A
COMMITTEE WILL BE RESPONSIVE
PROACTIVE IN ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF OUR AGRICULTURAL- OUR
CONSTITUENTS I'VE BEEN DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I MYSELF
HAVING GROWN UP IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA IN A REGION
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE AND INNOVATIVE
AGRICULTURAL AREAS IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD OFTEN KNOWN AS THE
SELLABLE CAPITAL THE WORLD. OUR
AGRICULTURAL HERITAGE IS- IS
IMPORTANT IT IS PERSONAL TO ME
HI AND A CONTINUES TO BE A
SOURCE OF GREAT PRIDE FOR MY
FAMILY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
LEADING THIS COMMITTEE- WORKING
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE THAT IT CONTINUES
TO BE THE MOST INNOVATIVE
NOURISHING. AND PRODUCTIVE LAND
ON THE PLANET- AND TO SOME
LOGISTICS. AND PROTOCOLS FOR
THIS HEARING AND DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN THIS ROOM.
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. AS A RESULT WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON. HERE IN
THIS ROOM WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN AT ALL
TIMES- THAT PHYSICAL- THAT THE
SOCIAL AND PHYSICAL. DISTANCING
BE MAINTAIN BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- THAT THE WORD OF
THOSE NUMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN THIS
HEARING WHETHER THAT'S IN THIS
ROOM OR AT VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. FOR PARTIS THAT ARE
PRESENT HERE WITH US AND FOR
VISITORS IN THIS ROOM IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK ONE CAN OR WILL
BE PROVIDED FOR YOU- IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THIS
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME
PANELS MAKING USE OF THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM.
HERE IN THE CAPITOL BUILDING-
THESE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
SCREEN. SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THIS HEARING ROOM
AND WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO ASK
THEM QUESTIONS YOU KNOW FINALLY
I WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
HOLD. THEIR QUESTIONS UNTIL THE
END OF EACH PANEL AND SO WITH
THAT. YOU KNOW THE PURPOSE OF
OUR HEARING THIS AFTERNOON- IS
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION. TO LEARN
ABOUT THE IMPACTS SUSTAINED BY
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DUE TO.
RECENT WILDFIRES. AND TO
EXPLORE POLICIES NEEDED TO
AVOID- AND MITIGATE THESE
IMPACTS IN FUTURE YEARS. THIS
YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY IT HAS
BEEN THE LARGEST MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE SEASON
EVER RECORDED IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY- THIS YEAR- AND JUST
RECENTLY IN RECENT MONTHS
WILDFIRES HAVE BURNED MORE THAN
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION ACRES
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION ACRES.
THE AUGUST COMPLEX FIRE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST
FIRE IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
BURNED OVER ONE MILLION ACRES.
I IN FACT SIX OF THE TEN
LARGEST RECORDED FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY HAPPENED
JUST THIS YEAR. WHILE THESE
FIRES HAVE RAGED IT SEEMS THAT
NO MATTER WHERE YOU RESIDED
HERE IN OUR STATE. THERE WAS NO
ESCAPING THEIR IMPACT. WE ALL
SAW IT FROM THE DARKENED RED
SKIES. TO THE CHARRED HILLSIDES
A WE ALL STRUGGLED THROUGHOUT
THE SUMMER WITH SEVERELY
UNHEALTHY AIR. THAT SEEMS TO
LINGER FOR MONTHS ON END- AND
THE IMPACT AGRICULTURE. WAS
ABSOLUTELY PROFOUND- IN
ADDITION TO THE EXTREMELY TOXIC
IMPACT OF WILDFIRE SMOKE ON
WORKERS FRESH PRODUCE IN MY
DISTRICT- AND ACROSS OUR STATE
PRODUCE SUCH AS SPINACH LETTUCE
STRAWBERRIES GRAPES. WERE
EXPOSED TO ASH TO SMOKE AND
COULD NOT BE HARVESTED. AS A
RESULT CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
THIS YEAR MORE THAN EVER. BORE
A HEAVY TOLL A HEAVY TOLL.
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF
PRODUCTIVE AGRICULTURAL LAND
BURNED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WITH
THE PRODUCING GRAPES RUINED. SO
TODAY WE WILL BE HEARING FROM
FARMERS- WILL BE HEARING FROM
RANCHERS AND AGRICULTURAL
ORGANIZATIONS. ALL OF WHOM HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF
RECENT WILDFIRES. WE WILL HEAR
ABOUT THEIR IMPACT AND ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES- AND WHAT WE
HOPE WE CAN DO TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF FUTURE WILDFIRES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS CLEAR
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES ARE NOT
GOING AWAY. I AND WE MUST BE
BETTER PREPARED FOR WHEN THEY
RETURN. I AND IT'S ALSO CLEAR
THAT AGRICULTURE MUST BE A
LEADER IN THIS DISCUSSION-
AGRICULTURE MUST BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION IN MITIGATING THE
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRES AND I
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY. I GIVE
I'D LIKE TO GIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE WHO JUST JOINED US- AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY SOME
COMMENTS. THAT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WELCOME TO.
BEING THE CHAIR OF AGRICULTURAL
AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR. DOING
YOUR STATEWIDE AGRICULTURAL
TOUR WHEN HE GOT THE NEWS THAT
YOU WERE- GIVEN THE POSITION
AND COMING DOWN TO MY DISTRICT
AND SPENDING TIME THERE AND-
BEAN BOOTS ON THE GROUND- NO
MEANS A LOT TO OUR-
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY TO SEE
MEMBERS- ACTUALLY GET THEIR
BOOTS DIRTY. AND YOU DID SHALL.
ON ONE OF YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER- IN IN
COMMITTEE STAFF- VICTOR AND
EVERYONE. YOU KNOW I THINK WITH
THE- WILDFIRES AS A VAN AS THE
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE REALLY
LOOKING AT THE MITIGATION
ASPECTS ON WHAT WE CAN DO
BETTER- AND WE KNOW. THAT
AGRICULTURE HAS THE ABILITY TO
LEAD THE WAY AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF MITIGATIONS WITHIN THE
AG INDUSTRY THAT WE CAN DO THAT
ARE ACTUALLY- PROTECT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION- TO OUR PANELISTS
AND SHEDDING SOME MORE LIGHT ON
WHAT IS TRUTHFULLY OUT THERE
THAT CAN BE DONE. ON ESPECIALLY
SOME OF THE GRAZING PRACTICES
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE MORE USE OF AND
HOPEFULLY SHINE SOME MORE LIGHT
ON- WHAT WE CAN DO IN THAT
SPACE TO DO A BETTER JOB ACROSS
THE STATE SO THANK YOU FOR. THE
BIGGEST QUESTION LEVINE TO. I.
THANK YOU MUCH MR AND THANK YOU
AS WELL AS VICE CHAIR IT'S
AMAZING TO THINK ABOUT THE
AGRICULTURE- POWER. OF K. I'VE
BEEN- FARMS BOTH IN. IN BOTH
YOUR DISTRICTS TULARE AND MARK
COUNTY AND OF COURSE IN CINEMA
COUNTY- ACROSS THIS WHOLE. THE
EACH. MIGHT THAT. REPRESENTS
THE JOB IT RIGHT THE INSULAR.
BENEFITS TO THE WHOLE STATE-
THAT REPRESENTS THE FOOD
PRODUCTION. THAT LANDS ON THE
PLATE OF BOTH- SO MANY
AMERICANS IN AND CALIFORNIANS
BUT ALSO PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD. IT TELLS A FANTASTIC
STORY FOR CALIFORNIA. AND IT SO
IT WOULD BE EASY. TOO EASY-
REPRESENTING SOME COUNTY TO
THINK I CAN WE JUST PLEASE STOP
THESE WILDFIRES JUST BEEN TOO
MANY FOR TOO MANY YEARS- BUT I
KNOW EVERYONE ACROSS THE STATE.
FEELS THE VERY SAME WAY IT'S A
IT'S SOME OF THOSE AFFECTED THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND- IT ALONE IT'S AFFECTING
THE ENTIRE CITY CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW IT'S AFFECTING
AGRICULTURE. IN EVERY CORNER OF
CALIFORNIA SO- I THINK IT'S
REALLY GOOD- AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING- WE CAN'T LET THAT LET
LEFT AUSTIN AND LOOK BACK ON
OUR FOCUS ON HOW. WILDFIRES ARE
IMPACTING CALIFORNIA AND FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE OF ITS IMPACTS ON THE
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS EVERY
SINGLE PART OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. I THOSE COMMENTS AND
CA AGREE MORE WITH- BUT CHAIR
AND SOME OF OUR LIVE. WILL MOVE
ON TO A FIRST PANEL FIRST INTO
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW. OF
RECENT. IN OUR STATE AND THE IN.
ON LIKE TO OUR FIRST PANEL. TO
SEE. IF I MISSED YOUR NAME.
APOLOGIZE. IT'S A CHEAP NICK
SCHULER- HE'S THE- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CAN WITH CAL FIRE.
WILL BE JOINING US FROM THE
WITH VIDEO ROOMS. SO CHIEF WHEN
YOU'RE READY TAKE IT AWAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
NICK SCHULER AND I'M ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THE
ISSUE OF WILDFIRE TRENDS IN
CALIFORNIA. LIKE TO START BY
TALKING ABOUT THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRE SEASON. WITHOUT A DOUBT
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN AMONG THE
MOST DAMAGING AND DESTRUCTIVE
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY. SO FAR
WE HAVE HAD MORE THAN NINETY
TWO HUNDRED WILDFIRES IGNITE.
ACROSS THE STATE. WHICH
COLLECTIVELY HAVE BURNED MORE
THAN FOUR TWO POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES DESTROYED OVER NINETY
THREE HUNDRED STRUCTURES AND
KILLED THIRTY TWO INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING THREE FIRST
RESPONDERS. SIX OF THE TWENTY
LARGEST WILDFIRES IN OUR
HISTORY HAVE OCCURRED THIS YEAR
INCLUDING THE MASSIVE AUGUST
COMPLEX WHICH ALONE BURNED MORE
THAN ONE MILLION ACRES ACROSS
SIX COUNTIES. WHAT'S UNUSUAL
ABOUT THIS YEAR ASIDE FROM THE
STAGGERING FIGURES IS A MOST
LARGE FIRES HAVE BEEN THE
RESULT OF LIGHT. BEGINNING ON
ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DRY LIGHTNING STRIKES OVER
SEVERAL DAYS ACROSS CENTRAL AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RESULTING
IN NINE HUNDRED FIRES.
CALIFORNIA HAS IT EXPERIENCED
LIGHTNING SEEDS LIKE THIS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND A
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SIEGE ONLY
HUB ABOUT A THIRD OF THE NUMBER
OF LIGHTNING STRIKES THAT WE
SAW THIS PAST AUGUST. THE MAN.
I WHICH FIRE BURNED WELL
UNPRECEDENTED. AND ACTIVISTS
CAN THROUGH THE STATE. FROM THE
CO. OF MONTEREY COUNTY TO
OUTSKIRTS. OF QUINCY PLUMAS
COUNTY TO THE NOT FOREST. AND
TULARE CAN. WEEKS LATER A SET
OF FIRES OCCURRED LABOR DAY
WEEK FUELED BY HIGH TO. AND DR
ED. REYES IN FOR DOWN. AND TO
SHOW ACROSS OUR STATE. AT THE
P. OF THIS YEAR C. MORE THAN
NINETY THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS
ARE BATTLING. ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WITH MANY OF THESE FIRES
OCCURRING IN AREAS PREVIOUSLY
DEVASTATED BY FIRE LIKE NAPA
COUNTY. THIS SIEGE HAS TAKEN
ITS TOLL ON OUR FIREFIGHTERS
AND THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE
SERVE. THIS YEAR RECORD FIRE
SEASON IMPACTED JUST ABOUT
EVERY COMMUNITY IN THE STATE
INCLUDING THOSE FAR AWAY FROM
THE FIRE PERIMETER. SAN
FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE
EXPERIENCED RECORD UNHEALTHY
AIR LEVELS FOR SEVERAL WEEKS
AND PROMPTED AUTHORITIES TO
ISSUE SPARE THE AIR ALERTS. FOR
AT LEAST THIRTY CONSECUTIVE
DAYS. NATIONAL HEAR IN MORE
DETAIL FROM OTHER WITNESSES IN
TODAY'S HEARING THAT SAME
WILDFIRE SMOKE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED OUR CULTURE ACROSS THE
STATE. CAL FIRE AND CDFA HAVE
PRODUCED AN ONLINE MAP
OVERLAYING CALIFORNIA'S
FARMLANDS WHAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY WILDFIRE PERIMETERS YEAH
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS THE WIN. IF
YOU DON'T ALREADY HAVE AG TO
THE- I. WANT TO. THIS YEAR
SHOWS THAT Y. CAN AND DO OCCUR
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. FROM
OREGON TO THE MEXICAN BORDER
FROM THE OCEAN TO THE DESERT.
WHILE WATER FIRST RIGHT PART OF
OUR STATE'S LANCE. YES OF
CHANGE FIRE SUPPRESSION
ACTIVITIES. OVERGROWN FORESTS
AND A PROLONGED DROUGHT HAVE
RESULTED IN ON FOR SRI MORE. IN
OUR FORESTS ELEMENTARY THE NEW
SIZE AND SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE
WITNESSED NINE ALMOST HALF OF
THE TWENTY LARGEST FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. LOOKING
BACK A BIT FURTHER SEVENTEEN OF
THE TWENTY LARGEST WILDFIRES
HAVE OCCURRED SINCE THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND. RECENTLY WILDFIRE
TRENDS CLEARLY DEMONSTRATE THAT
PEAK FIRE SEASON IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE WEST IS STARTING
EARLIER AND ENDING LATER EACH
YEAR. CLIMATE CHANGE IS A KEY
DRIVER OF THIS TREND. WARMER
SPRING AND SUMMER TEMPERATURES.
REDUCED SNOWPACK AND EARLY
EARLY SPRING SNOW GREATLY. AND
MORE INTENSE SEASONS IS THAT
INCREASE MORTGAGE STRESS. ON
VEGETATE. AND FOR US AND OUR
LANDSCAPES MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
WILD. CLIMA CHANGE IS AN IS
ACTING AS A MORE. THE WAY
INCREASING THINGS CAL WILD.
OVER THE COME DECADE. WE CAN
EXPECT TO EXPERIENCE LONGER
FIRE SEASONS INCREASED
FREQUENCY AND SEVERITY OF
DROUGHT GREATER ACREAGE BURNED
A RELATED SECONDARY IMPACTS
SUCH AS WIDESPREAD TREE
MORTALITY AND BARK BEETLE
INFESTATION. WELL IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE TO ELIMINATE WILDFIRES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOCUSED AND
DELIBERATE ACTION CAN PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IMPROVE
FUELS CONDITIONS TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO BETTER COEXIST
WITH WILDFIRE. ADOPTING A
WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA'S DRY
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE REQUIRES
A SYSTEMATIC. ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH. THIS MEANS
IDENTIFYING AND MAPPING FIRE
HAZARD AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. ACTED A NEIGHBOR AND CAN.
FROM WILDFIRE THROUGH LAN SCAPE
SCALE YOUR- AND FOREST HEALTH.
PLANNING COMMUNITIES THAT RE TO
WHY. WITH FUEL BREAKS GREEN.
YEAH AND AROUND THE CAN.
ENSURING HAVE PROPER ABOUT
ROUTES WATER SUPPLY AND FIRE
RESOURCES. BILL HOMES AND
RESIST BUT WELL MAIN THEIR FEET
OF THE FOR SPACE BAR. DEAD AND
OVER GROW VEGETATION AND
EDUCATING THE TO PREVENT THE
START AND SPREAD OF HUMAN
BECAUSE WILDFIRES. IT IS A
UNDERSTANDING NO END TASK OR
PROGRAM IS A SILVER BULLET. AND
EACH ONE OF THESE EFFORTS WORKS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE OTHER
TO PREVENT AND PROTECT AGAINST
WILDFIRES. EACH REPRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX
THAT MUST BE ADOPTED FOR USE IN
PARTICULAR AREAS BASED ON
WEATHER PATTERNS. VEGETATION
TYPES TOPOGRAPHY AND THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. CALIFORNIA'S
PARTNERS ACROSS GOVERNMENT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FULLY COMMITTED
TO THIS ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH. WHICH WILL PUT
CALIFORNIA ON A TRAJECTORY AWAY
FROM INCREASINGLY DESTRUCTIVE
FIRES AND TOWARD A MOVE.
MODERATE YEAH MANAGEABLE REGIME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
LOOK FOR THE ANSWERING ANY YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU CHIEF AT
THE SMALL I BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
GONNA RESERVE QUESTIONS INTEL-
THE CONCLUSION OF THE PANEL
IT'S ALL THE SPEAKERS. I HAVE A
GUN THIS MOMENT- WOULD LIE TO
INVITE OUR NET PANELIST IS.
WHICH IS DOCKED DAN SUMNER.
DIRECTOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL ISSUES
I HE WILL BE JOINING US BY
PHONE- MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR DOCTOR
SUMNER. THANK YOU CHIEF. THIS
IS DAN SUMMER DO YOU HEAR. YES
WE CAN. MR SUMNER AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US
AFTERNOON. RIGHT SO I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT ECONOMIC LOSSES TO
ADD TO AGRICULTURE IN THE FIRST
THING I HAVE TO SAY IS THAT-
THE CONSEQUENCES THE ONCE WE
REALLY- ALL DO IN AND NEED
FOCUS OUR LOS APPLY ANSWER AND
IN- INTEREST INDIVIDUAL. IT
ALSO LOS THE HOME AND TRY THE
REALLY IT TEMPAT TO PUT A MA
LOSS AFTER SAY THAT. BECAUSE
NOW I'M GONNA TURN TO A BUNCH
OF DOLLARS DOLLAR LAW. BUT I
NONE OF US CAN SIGHT OF THE
THINGS THAT WE REALLY HAVE A
VERY HARD TIME THINKING OF IN
TERMS A DOLLARS AND CENTS. AND
IT'S MANY OF THE FARM FAMILIES
AND OPERATORS AND FORMER
EMPLOYEES THERE ARE. THOSE THAT
ARE AFFECTED BY TRAGIC LOSSES
SO THIS IS ALSO AN AGRICULTURAL
ISSUE BUT AGAIN IT'S ONE THAT
I'M NOT GONNA TRY TO QUANTIFY
THIS MORNING OR TIS AFTERNOON.
WELL IT AND TO THE CHIEF. ONE
OF THE THINGS AND I'LL COME BY
TO THIS THE END I THINK. OF
THIS YEAR- THERE I'M NOT GO
BACK A COUPLE OF YEARS WERE WE
CAN HAVE ALREADY SOME CAL. OF
EAGLE LOSSES. BUT THE THINGS
THAT WERE DIFFERENT THIS YEAR
IS THE- WERE EARLY. COMPARED TO
THE ONE IN STATE SO. AND. AND
THAT THEY HAD SOME. OF UP AMONG.
WAS THE SMOKE DAMAGE. NOT JUST
IT. COURSE SMOKE DAMAGE- IS IN
THREAT. TO HELP ON. DAYS IN THE
LIKE. AND I JUST WANT TO SHOULD.
MAKE THE THAT FORMER ARE AMONG
THE- THAT ARE OUT THERE EVERY
DAY. WORKING IN CAN. WE ALL
KNOW WITH. THEY CAN BE. AND
ALSO WITH THAT ERIC. AND YET.
IF THE CROPS ARE GOING TO BE
HARPER AT THE- OF ARE GOING TO.
SOMEBODY'S TO BE OUT THERE
DOING IT I WANT TO SEE. THAT
YEAH I'LL SPEND A LITTLE MORE
TIME I HAVE NO QUAN OF THOSE.
OF ECONOMIC Mà ARE THEY- WE
KNOW HOW DO IT A- GOOD AT IT-
IN BAR ECONOMY WORKING A GROUP.
ECONOMIST BUT IT HAS BEEN DONE
AS FAR AS I KNOW FOR A TWENTY
TWENTY. OF FARMWORKER- IMPACT
OF A BETTER QUALITY. ALL WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A TO DATE ACCURATE
ASSESS FOR TWENTY. THEREFORE
WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS GO BACK.
UP TO LOW AT IT WHAT WE'VE DONE
SAY ON THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FIRES WERE WEAK THERE HAS BEEN
MORE CALCULATIONS DONE WITH
OBJECTIVE DATA. AND SOME WELL
WE HAVE A LITTLE MORE COMPLETE
INFORMATION- AGGREGATE
ASSESSMENTS ARE NEEDED OF
COURSE AND- THEN THEY NEED TO
USE OBJECTIVE MODELING AND
DETAILED DATA. TO CALCULATE
LOST INCOME AND WEALTH AND ALSO
JOBS AND I THINK THAT'S-
SOMETHING THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A SET OF
FAIRLY DRY CALCULATIONS. WELL
LET ME START WITH A COUPLE OF-
FACTS AND FIGURES JUST TO PUT
ALL OF THIS IN PERSPECTIVE. A
CALIFORNIA'S PRODUCING ABOUT
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OF
AGRICULTURAL INCOME EVERY YEAR.
THAT SALES OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS- IT VERY TO GOES UP
AND DOWN DEPENDING ON PRICES
AND WHAT THE WEATHER GIVES US.
ALL HOPE THAT ABOUT THE TWELVE
POINT THREE BILLION IS PAID TO
EMPLOYEES AND CONTRACT LABOR SO
A BIG CHUNK OF THAT GOES TO THE
WORKERS. ALL BUT DOT NET
RETURNS TO FARMERS OR ABOUT TEN
BILLION. AND THE REST GOES FOR
A- ALL EXPENSES ON FORM SO THAT
THE NET IS A LOT SMALLER THAN
THE GROSS. IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE RESOURCE BASED ON THIS OF
AG. DATA WHICH IS THE BEST WE
HAVE WHICH IS TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS WORTH
THE VALUE AND FARMLAND AND
RANGE AND BUILDINGS AND THE
LIKE MOST OF THAT LAND BUT OUR
SISTER SUBSTANTIAL PART IS
OTHER REALESTATE- BUILT REAL
ESTATE. MACHINERY IS ABOUT.
BILLION DOLLARS TERMS OF
FARMLAND WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ACRES ABOUT EIGHT
MILLION OF THAT IS THE
HARVESTED CROPLAND ABOUT
THIRTEEN MILLION AS PASTOR AND
THEN THERE'S ADDITIONAL
ACREAGE- AS WELL. BOB DRAWING
THE LINE BETWEEN AGRICULTURE
AND THE REST THE COMMIES NOT
EASY HERE I'M GONNA FOCUS WE
DON'T HAVE MUCH TIME I'M GONNA
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON FARM
LOSSES I'M NOT GOING TO PROVIDE
DATA ON LOSSES IN PROCESSING
AND MARKETING WE KNOW THAT PART
OF AGRICULTURE IT IS VERY HARD
TO SEPARATE AGRICULTURAL
PROCESSING SAY FROM OTHER
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRIES FOOD
PROCESSING IS OFTEN INCLUDED
WITHIN AGRICULTURE BUT IT'S
ALSO INCLUDED WITHIN THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRIES AND
I'M GONNA FOCUS ON SOME TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NUMBERS TO GIVE US
EXAMPLES TO WORK WITH. AND ALL
START WITH VENTURA ALL WERE THE
THOMAS FIRE WHICH AFFECTED NOT
JUST BEEN TOUR BUT SURROUNDING
AREAS AS WELL INCLUDING SANTA
BABARA COUNTY ALL THE
COMMISSIONER OF AGRICULTURE
MADE SOME ESTIMATES RIGHT AWAY
ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
PASTURE. ABOUT TENTH ACRES OF
IRRIGATED CROPLAND IN THIS SORT
OF PATTERN MOSTLY IT'S PAST
YOUR LAND. IS TRUE FOR ALL THE
WILDFIRES THAT I'VE LOOKED AT.
OR ALMOST ALL OF THE BIG ONES.
OUT THERE OF THE THOMAS FIRE
THERE WERE ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
ACRES OF AVOCADOS THAT WERE
AFFECTED. ALSO CITRUS. THESE
ARE VERY HIGH VALUE CROPS THAT
ARE AFFECTED THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY THAT THOMAS FIRE FIRE. THE
COMMISSIONER ESTIMATED THE
DIRECT AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIC
LOSS AT THE FARM LEVEL. AT
ABOUT SEVENTY MILLION. AND THEN
ESTIMATED ON ANOTHER HUNDRED
MILLION. IN AGRICULTURAL
DWELLINGS AND THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE THAT IS. FAIRLY
GENERAL- CALIFORNIA MAKES A
VERY GOOD ASSESSMENT OF
STRUCTURES THAT ARE DAMAGED AND
DWELLINGS THAT ARE DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
OF MUCH OF THE DAMAGE THE
ECONOMIC DAMAGE OF FIRES
HAPPENS WITH THAT A DAMAGE TO
STRUCTURES. BOB IN THE THOMAS
FIRE THE WERE ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS EACH IN LAW. OF THE
VALUE THE CROP THAT WERE AT ON
THE TREES THAT WAS A CODE
COTTO'S INSPECTOR. GIVEN THE
TIME OF THE FAR IN THE TIME OF
THE HEART. OF FAIRLY ON YOU. IN
THE THAT MOST CROSS- SHARES
THAT HAVE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
MOST WOULD BE HARDEST. BY THE
TIME I A FOR IN NOVEMBER. IT
BUT THAT'S TRUE FOR CITRUS OF
COURSE OR FOR A- THE CAPITAL.
IN THE THOMAS FIRE WERE ABOUT
FIFTEEN DOLLARS. AND THAT WAS
DAMAGE TO THE TREES THEMSELVES
AS AN ASSET. AGRICULTURAL
STRUCTURES OF THE BARNES AND
FACILITIES AND EQUIPMENT. AND
THAT SORT OF PATTERN. OF IS
QUITE BROAD. THE LOSS TO THE
PASTURE LAND WAS RELATIVELY
SMALL PER ACRE EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS SIXTY MILLION ACRES. THERE
WERE FENCES AND STRUCTURES I
DON'T SAY I DON'T WANT TO SAY
IT WAS A SMALL NUMBER IT WAS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS- BUT BUT
PER ACRE. WELL WE KNOW THAT
BURNING THE PAST YOUR LAND
YOU'RE NOT DESTROYING A CROP
GENERALLY AND PARTICULARLY IF
IT'S IN THE FALL. ALL IT GROW
BACK. AND I. OF THE LAW A
FORMER IS NODDING IN WHAT THE
CA. DID ALL THAT WAS VERY
VALUABLE ESTIMATES RIGHT AFTER
THE THOMAS FIRE. LET ME TURN IN.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA QUICKLY. OF
THE NORTH BAY FIRE OF TWO
SEVEN- COURSE IN THE NORTH BIG
SAN WAS HIT NAPA SLAW- A LAY
MENACING ALL OF THEM ALL THE
WAY UP. IT ALSO IN THIS VALLEY
BUTTE YUBA K. ABOUT FIVE EIGHT
THERE THE ABOUT TWO OR TWO THAT
YEAR IN THE NORTH BAY. MUCH OF
THAT WE- RANGING A PATH. DAMAGE
TO FENCES STRAW FACILITY
EQUIPPED. ALL CALCULATION
ARRIVED SIXTY WAS A TEN DOLLARS
IF YOU THINK OF THE ECRI IN THE
AMOUNT OF FENCING STRUCTURE
THAT WERE GOING ALONG THAT
HELLO IT'S- WE WERE BURNING
ACROSS SO YOU LOSE THAT. IN THE
GREAT WAS PRETTY COME BY THE
TIME ALL THE YEAR WAS OVER IN
THE- OF FOR WILL COME BACK IN
THIS. BUT THE BIGGEST LOSS WILL
TREASON FIND AND THEIR PART-
LEVINE- SO EXT VOTE VICE PER
ACRE LIVING LAND. IT'S OFTEN
CAL. IN THE BEST WAY TO CAL IT
IS SAY WHAT THE LAND WORKED
WITH VINEYARD. WHAT PLAN WHAT
THE BARE LAND WORTH THE YOU CAN.
ON AND THAT TELLS YOU THE
DIFFERENT IN IT IN THE RAIN OF
A HUNDRED THOUSAND IN IN- THE
AVERAGE FOR NAPA COUNTY IN SOME
LESS PER RE SIX GET DOWN TO
TWENTY A I USE FOR SOME **** OF
FIFTY TO EIGHT FOR THE FOR THE
AREA- FORTY. VINES ARE RE TO
FIVE. BUT EVEN IF THE VINES
OKAY. ARE YOU CAN BURN
EXPENSIVE TROUBLES AND
IRRIGATION SO. ALL PUTTING THE
IN THE CAR. THERE WERE ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED OF OUR WITHIN THE
FIRE. USING THEM. THAT CAL. SO
YOU GET A LOT OF ABOUT TWO
FIVE. OF THE ACRES OF FIVE AND-
NOW IN FARM- GOOD LOSSES. A
WHINER STRUCTURE IN OTHER. AND
I HAVEN'T INCLUDE THOSE SO AND
THEY'RE PROBABLY AT LEAST AS
LONG AS THE LOS OF TO THE THING
THEMSELVES. WELL DOCTOR
PROBABLY I SAW I HAVE TO CUT
YOU OFF THERE TO REALLY
APPRECIATE. WE SURE WHAT SOME.
AT THE BUT WE ARE WERE UP THE
TIME BUT REAL PRETTY YOUR TIME
AND ALL THE INFORMATION. ALL OF.
YEAH I'LL STAY ON THE LINE IN
CASE THERE. THANK YOU DON AND
SO AT THIS TIME OF THE FOR.
SPEAKER ON THIS PANEL. WILL BE
FROM CDFA. A DEPUTY SAID.
ADMINISTRATION AND FINANCE AT
THE DEPARTMENT- KEVIN. MASSIEU
HARA- MR MASAHARU IF I
MISPRONOUNCE A NAME AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE BUT- YOU ARE UP WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO GO. I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN RIVAS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- YEAH YOU'RE
PRETTY CLOSE KEVIN LAWSUIT ARE
AT SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG- MY ARA
IS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
FINANCE- YEAH THERE'S A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT I'M GOING TO
PRESENT HERE TODAY TO UPDATE
YOU ON RELATED TO THE
WILDFIRES. OF THE FIRST ONE IS
THE FAIR GROUNDS BECAUSE THEY
PLAY A PRETTY IMPORTANT ROLE WE
HAVE DISASTERS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES. IN THE SECONDARY
WILL BE SPECIFIC TO THE ANIMAL
CARE PROGRAM WHICH IS A PROGRAM
HOUSED AT OUR DEPARTMENT. I'M
BY WAY OF OVER OF THE- NETWORK
OF FAIR ARE SO SEVEN TOTAL AND
CAL. AND THERE'S VERY ANSWER
THERE IS STRUCTURE THAT WERE.
GOVERN HOW THESE VERY ARE YOU
THAT ALL OF THEM GET. IN DUTY
WHEN THE DURING. VANCE. AND FOR
THE PERIOD WORK A- FIFTY DE
FARES ARE. FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE DURING WHILE SEE. AND
I'LL GIVE YOU A ROUGH BREAK OF
THAT OF HOW THE WERE YOU TO.
THIRTY THREE OF THEM WERE IN
THE SHOW OF THE- TWENTY TWO
USED AS A VACUUM SITE. AND
TWENTY ONE WERE USED AS STAGING
COME CENTER ARE BASED- MATH ON
THAT DOES ADD UP TO SAID
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
FAIRGROUNDS ARE LOW PROPER. AND
SO THEY ARE MULTI PURPOSE AND
SO THEY MOM MORE ONE ROLE
DURING A. AND DURING THE PERIOD
THERE WERE. ALMOST EIGHT
THOUSAND. WERE SHELTERED AT THE
FAIR. AND CLOSE THREE THOUSAND
ABOUT. WERE HOUSED AT
FAIRGROUNDS DURING THE PERIOD.
AND OVER TWENTY TWO. MERGING
WAS FIRST. GRASPING THIS PERIOD
SO. IT'S CAN SEE THE- OF VITAL
TO THE RESP. AND HELPING TO
SUPPORT THE RESPONSE. AND WHEN
YOU DO THIS- A THOROUGH
COLLECTIVE. ON THESE VERY
GROUNDS WERE A THEIR THEIR
UTILIZE FOR TOLD OF NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT DAYS
DURING THIS YOU KNOW SO THAT'S
A PRETTY SUB COME AT LEAST
GROUND FOR THE FIRST OF. I TO
THE ANIMAL CARE IS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET THROUGH
THIS HEARING I'LL TRY TO KEEP
THIS ONE BRIEF AS WELL THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE BUT I DON'T KNOW
THAT. THAT'S GOING TO SERVE
THIS COMMITTEE- TOO WELL SO WE
CAN GET INTO THAT LATER IF YOU
DO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THE ANIMAL CARE Z. AS IT STANDS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
RESPONSE EMERGENCY SYSTEM AND
THAT'S A STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS ANIMALS IN
DISASTERS. AND HERE IS A
SUPPORTED BY A PARTNERSHIP OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT COMMIT
RESOURCES AND EXPERTISE TO
PREPARING FOR. AND RESPONDING
TO ANIMALS IN DISASTERS.
BERSEDIA BASIL AND CARERS WE
STEP THIRTY NINE RESPONSE
POSITION ROTATIONS TO SUPPORT
COUNTY ANIMAL SERVICES AND WE
HAD A DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS
CENTER THAT ACTIVATED FOR THE
MAJOR FIRES DURING TWENTY
TWENTY- IN CARRYING THIS OUT WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER AT CALLOWAY
YES. TO FACILITATE THE COUNTY'S
REQUEST FOR MISSION TASKING
STATE RESOURCES REQUEST FOR
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE AND STATE TO
STATE MUTUAL AID REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES THROUGH THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE COMPACT.
CDFA ALSO DEPLOYED A PARCEL
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM TO
STAFF THE BUTTE COUNTY
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER FOR
THE NORTH COMPLEX FIRE WITH
CONTINUOUS SUPPORT FOR FOUR
WEEKS. CDFA ALSO DEPLOYED STAFF
TO TRINITY COUNTY TO ASSESS THE
RECOVERY EFFORTS. IN THE AREAS
OF ANIMAL MORTALITY MANAGEMENT
LIVESTOCK HERE FEEDING NEEDS
THEIR- AND JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
THE BACKGROUND I TOLD I WOULD
GET TOO DEEP INTO IT BUT TEARS
BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN- BUT OVER THE
YEARS. THE RESOURCE LEVELS HAVE
VARIED AND WE'RE SUBJECT TO
BUDGET CUTS ABOUT A DECADE AGO
BUT DURING THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET WE WERE
SEATED- THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS HANG OUT. SOME
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT SO THAT WE
CAN BEGIN TO STAFF UP AND THEY
HAVE DEDICATED STAFF TO THIS.
AB RIGHT HERE AND SO WE'VE
COMPLETED- THE HIRES OF THOSE
THREE FOLKS WITH LEVERAGE THAT
TO TRAIN OTHER PEOPLE.
THROUGHOUT ORGANIZATION AND
CDFA TO BE ABLE TO BE
RESPONSIVE IN THE- IDYLLWILD
FIRE BUT ANY OTHER TYPE OF
SITUATION WHERE ANIMAL CARE. IS
NECESSARY. AND WITH THAT I'LL
GO HEAD AND STOP THERE I KNOW
THAT YOU WERE HOLDING QUESTIONS
BACK FOR THE ENTIRE PANEL AT
ONCE AND SO WE CAN MOVE INTO
THAT PICTURE PLEDGE MISTER CARE.
WHAT YOU. MR- MUSCLE HARA AND
SO AT THIS TIME- THIRTY
QUESTIONS OF FOR OUR FIRST
PANEL- NOW WOULD BE THE TIME TO
ASK. DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
AND EVERYTHING NOW IF YOU GET
OKAY I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION- A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ACTUALLY-
THE FIRST PROBABLY SHOULD BE
FOR- CAL FIRE- JUST FOR A-
CHIEF SURE- AND I KNOW JEAN
FULLER YOU HAD MENTIONED IN
YOUR STATEMENTS THAT WHAT WE
CAN EXPECT IN FUTURE MONTHS AND
YEARS WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA IS
GREATER ACREAGE WILL BE BURNED.
AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE CURRENT
INTERACTION OR THE POTENTIAL
FOR INTERACTION OF CAL FIRE AND
AGRICULTURE. YET WE KNOW WHEN
IT COMES TO PREVENTION
PLANNING- AND HOW AGRICULTURAL
LANDS. MAY PLAY A ROLE- A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE MITIGATION OF- WILDFIRE
AS AS WE MOVE INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION OF.
THIS REALLY TIES AND BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER AN INCIDENT IN
BEFORE AN INCIDENT OCCURS EACH
OF OUR MEMBERS OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OUR MEMBERS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY MEET WITH
LANDOWNERS COMMITTEES TO LOOK
AT SPECIFIC INCIDENTS SPECIFIC
AREAS OF INTEREST. WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. DURING THE
INCIDENTS OUR LIAISON STAFF IS
ALSO MEETING WITH WITH MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY DETERMINE
AREAS OF AS AN EXAMPLE THAT
NEED TO BE WATERED THAT ARE IN.
OF ACTUATION AREAS AREAS THAT
NEED TO BE HARVESTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHILE WE'RE
EVACUATING PEOPLE WHAT WE ARE
ALSO NOT DOING IS IMPACTING-
THE FINANCIAL IMPACTS EVEN
GREATER THAN WHAT THEY ALREADY
ARE. ADDITIONALLY SENATE BILL
NINE OH ONE PROVIDES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR A FIVE YEAR PERIOD
THE LOOKS OF FOREST HEALTH AND
FIRE PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAMS.
TO DETERMINE. AND MAKE SURE
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
COLLECTIVELY AS A STATE TO
PREPARE LANDSCAPE. EXCELLENT I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE CHIEF-
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL AND SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THIS PANEL-
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU GUYS MAKE
THE TIME FOR US IN THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. THANK YOU. AND
SO NOW FOR OUR SECOND PANEL-
THE FOCUS THE FOCUS OF THIS
PANEL IS GOING TO BE ON
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF THE
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRES TO
AGRICULTURE- FROM GROWERS
RANCHERS AND FARM WORKERS- I'D
LIKE TO LIKE TO INVITE OUR OUR
FIRST PANELISTS TO SPEAK MISTER
JAIME JO HANSON IS PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. NOW
HE'S HERE IN PERSON MR
JOHANNSSON WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SCRIPTS YOU. AND
CLARIFICATION WHERE DOES HE GET
THIS IS A STEP HERE TO COME TO
THE TABLE. OKAY YOU GOT
WHATEVER YOU PREFER. YEAH HE-
BECAUSE THE TABLE WORKS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YEAH MAYBE PLEASURE
TO BE WITH YOU JIM IF YOU LOWER
THE MICROPHONE LITTLE BIT LONG
TIME SINCE WE ARE IN THE
CAPITAL EVERYTHING GOING ON
THERE'S A TALK WITH YOU ABOUT
WILDFIRES I AM JIM JOHANNSON
PRESENT THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION THE STATE'S
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING THE
INTERESTS OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY FARMERS AND
RANCHERS I'M ALSO FORMER BUTTE
COUNTY. CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES A
VERY PERSONAL TO ME NOT AS
PRESENT THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU OR MY ORGANIZATION BUT
BECAUSE MY FAMILY AND MY
NEIGHBORS HAVE BEEN EVACUATED
THROUGHOUT THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
FOR WILDFIRES. I WEREN'T AS MY
TEST MY TO FOCUS ON THREE
COMPONENTS. OF THE STATE'S
WELFARE IMPACT ON AGRICULTURE
THE DIRECT IMPACT. THOSE WHO
HAVE HAD THEIR LIVESTOCK BURNED
TO DEATH OUR WINERIES AND
VINEYARDS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED OUR MEMBERS FOR THOSE
WHO CONTINUE TO PICK UP. THE
PIECES OF WHAT REMAINS. OF
THEIR OPERATION. OUR MEMBERS.
ARE FARMERS AND RANCHERS BUT
SOME ARE ALSO WILDFIRE VICTIMS.
THE INDIRECT IMPACT ALSO IS THE
FOCUS OF WHICH WILL BE ON THE
IMPACTS NOT NECESSARILY
DIRECTLY FROM A WILDFIRE BUT
RELATED TO IT SUCH AS SMOKE
TAINT. FOR EXAMPLE AND IMPACTS
TO OUR EMPLOYEES. OTHER RELATED
A RESIDUAL IMPACTS TO
AGRICULTURE THE INABILITY OF
OUR FARMS TO ACQUIRE INSURANCE
NOT FOR CROPS OR CROP DAMAGE
BUT IN ORDER TO PRESERVE OUR
BUSINESS INFRASTRUCTURE THE
UNRELIABLE DELIVERY ELECTRICITY
BECAUSE OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFFS AND THE INABILITY TO
SAFELY EVACUATE ANIMALS WHEN
COMMUNITIES FACE EVACUATION.
THESE ARE THE THREE COMPONENTS
THAT NO OTHER ORGANIZATION
CALIFORNIA FACES. AND THESE ARE
REAL CHALLENGES TO WHICH THE
STATE NEEDS TO MEET. HEAD ON.
THE FARM YOUR FAMILY
COLLECTIVELY WITH OUR COUNTY
FARMERS HAVE EXPERIENCED LOSS
JUST LIKE ALL CALIFORNIANS A
COMMUNITIES REELING FROM THE
LAST FOUR YEARS OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE. WITH GREATER
REGULARITY THESE WILDFIRES AND
NO LONGER STRONG JUST HOMES AND
DEVASTATING COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S FARMS RANCHES
EMPLOYEE HOUSING EQUIPMENT AND
A ROCK COMMODITIES HAVE BEEN
DAMAGED OR COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
THESE WILDFIRES DON'T
DISCRIMINATE AND ARE IGNORANT
TO JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S FEDERAL
STATE OR LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY
AREAS CALIFORNIA BURNED MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION ACRES OF LAND
THIS YEAR. THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRES IN NAPA COMPLETELY
DESTROYED BURGESS CELLARS CAIN
VINEYARD DUTCH HENRY WINERY AND
SURE ONE FAMILY VINEYARD ALL
FARM BUREAU MEMBERS. AND
ANOTHER TEN OPERATIONS AND
DOZENS MORE IN CINEMA COUNTY
WERE ALSO DESTROYED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NEARLY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED APPLICATIONS
FROM CINEMA COUNTY FARMERS HAVE
BEEN RECEIVED BY USDA'S FARM
SERVICE AGENCY. REQUESTING
ASSISTANCE RELATED TO FIRE THE
WILDFIRE DAMAGES AND THE
DESTRUCTION OF COMMODITIES.
IT'S NOT JUST CALIFORNIA'S
FARMING RANCHING COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HURTING FARMER ALSO
REPRESENTS TIMBER FAMILIES AND
THE WILDFIRES THAT DESTROYED
VIABLE COMMERCIAL TIMBER ACROSS
THE STATE. IN DOING SO NOT ONLY
HARMS THESE COMMERCIAL
OPERATIONS BUT ALSO ASSOCIATED
MILLS AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
THAT STILL RELY ON THESE
REVENUES. THOSE JOINING ME
TODAY WILL TELL YOU OF THEIR
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
GRUESOME. SOME OF IT HORRIFIC.
BUT IT'S THE REALITY IT'S A
SOMBER REMINDER OF HOW
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS
DIFFERENT AND HOW THE INABILITY
OF RESPONSIBILITY AGENCIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
THE INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY THE
LIVESTOCK. HAS RESULT IN
ARGUABLY AVOIDABLE TRAGEDY. THE
TOTAL WILDFIRE DAMAGES ARE
STILL BEING CALCULATED BUT
EARLY ESTIMATES HAVE TO HAVE IT
PEGGED AT APPROXIMATELY TEN
BILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS A
TOTAL ESTIMATE OF DAMAGE NOT
SPECIFIC JUST TO AGRICULTURE.
AS MENTIONED CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE ALSO FACES INDIRECT
WILDFIRE CHALLENGES. THIS YEAR
THE CHALLENGE WAS WILD FIRE
SMOKE AND ASH WE ALSO FACE THE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO PROVIDING
OUR EMPLOYEE WITH PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT GIVEN THE
EXISTING SHORTAGES RESULTING
FROM COVE IN NINETEEN. THE
ALLEN YOU COMPLEX FIRE COVERED
MUCH OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
WINE REGION IN A WEEKS LONG
BLANKET OF SMOKE AND ASH. ONLY
TO BE FOLLOWED BY THE GLASS
FIRE WHICH BURNED IN NAPA AND
SONOMA COUNTIES THAT WILL
LIKELY ACT AS THE KNOCKOUT
PUNCH. FOR THE WINERIES LOOKING
TO PRODUCE A TWENTY TWENTY
MANAGE. IT'S REPORTED THAT THE
GLASS FIRE COULD RESULT IN
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOSSES WHAT CROP
DAMAGE- FROM SMOKE AND ASH
RELATED TO THE ELLEN YOU
COMPLEX WILL POTENTIALLY BE IN
THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SMOKE AND ASH WASN'T CONFINED
JUST TO WINE GRAPE GROWING
REGIONS OF NAPA SONOMA. AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES. MONTEREY
COUNTY CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
COAST COUNTIES THE WINE GRAPE
GROWING REGIONS OF THE CENTRAL
SACRAMENTO VALLEY ALSO
EXPERIENCED WEEKS OF SMOKE AND
ASK ASH COVERAGE. THE WILDFIRE
SMOKE AND ASH FURTHER
EXASPERATED THE EXISTING
SHORTAGES RELATED TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF PP THE PAST IT
THIS PAST APRIL FARM BUREAU
SURVEYED OUR MEMBERSHIP TO GET
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING. OF THE
IMPACT OF COLLUDED NINETEEN WAS
HAVING ON THE FARM. NEARLY
SEVENTY PERCENT. REPORTED THAT
THE UNAVAILABILITY OF N. NINETY
FIVE RESPIRATORS AND OTHER
PROTECTIONS FOR EMPLOYEES. WAS
PREVENTING EVEN MOST USUAL
ACTIVITIES USUAL ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS HARVEST PLANTING AND
CULTIVATION FROM HAPPENING.
FARMERS WERE UNABLE TO SOURCE
AND NINETY FIVES ANOTHER PP FOR
PESTICIDE APPLICATIONS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. THE
EARLY ONSET OF THE WILDFIRE
SEASON MADE THE NEED AND
SHORTAGE MORE ACUTE. ACCORDING
TO CAL OSHA WORKPLACE
REGULATIONS EMPLOYERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROTECT OUTDOOR
WORKERS WITH N. NINETY FIVE
MASKS OR RESPIRATORS WHEN AIR
QUALITY INDEX IS A HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE OR GREATER. THE MOST
CURRENT SITUATION SHOWS THE
NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY BY STATE
REGULATORS. THE IMPACT OF
WILDFIRE SEASON COUPLED WITH
THE UNAVAILABILITY OF N. NINETY
FIVE RESPIRATORS DUE TO COVE
IT. CAL OSHA HADN'T APPROVED
ANYTHING THAT SERVES AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. SORE EXACTLY WHERE
WE WERE IN MARCH WHEN WE TOLD
THE AGENCY THAT THIS WAS GOING
TO BE A PROBLEM. PRIOR TO THE
WILD FIRES FARM BUREAU AND
OTHER GROUPS WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO ACQUIRE
ABOUT ONE AND A HALF MILLION
RESPIRATORS. THAT WERE RELEASED
TO THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS COMMISSIONERS
FROM THE STATE SUPPLIES. BUT AS
THE WILDFIRES BEGAN PEOPLE WHO
NEED THE RESPIRATORS COULDN'T
GET HIM. IN THE MEANTIME WE
NEED ACCEPTABLE ALTERNATIVES TO
N. NINETY FIVE RESPIRATORS.
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN IS RESOLVED. OR A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT THAT THE
STATE SET ASIDE A SUFFICIENT
STOCKPILE OF IN NINETY FIVE FOR
EVERY WILDFIRE SEASON TO HELP
FACILITATE DISTRIBUTION AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF PROTECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FARM RANCH
EMPLOYEES. AND OTHER RELATED
WILDFIRE IMPACT OUR CULTURE THE
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
WILL FOR THE FIRST TIME HERE OF
AN EMERGING ISSUE FACING
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. CALIFORNIA'S FAIR
PLAN THE TOUTED INSURER OF LAST
RESORT FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
HOMEOWNERS WILL NOT INSURE
CALIFORNIA'S FARMS AND RANCHES.
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW
SPECIFICALLY INSURANCE CODE ONE
ZERO ZERO NINE FOUR PROHIBITS
PREMIUMS FOR AUTOMOBILE OR FARM
RISK. IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
FARM RISK IS MORE LIKE
PRODUCTION RISK. OR MARKET RISK
OR FINANCIAL RISK INSTITUTIONAL
RISK IN HUMAN OR PERSONAL RISK
IN OTHER WORDS THIS IS WHY MOST
FARMING OPERATIONS CARRY CROP
INSURANCE AND PROVIDE BALANCE
MANAGEMENT THAT REDUCE
FINANCIAL AFFECTS THAT CAN
RESULT FROM SUCH UNCERTAINTIES.
THE FAIR PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE
PREMIUMS RELATED TO CROP
INSURANCE WE AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT IT SHOULD COVER OUR FARMING
AND RANCHING INFRASTRUCTURE
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER COMMERCIAL
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. RESOLVING THIS
ISSUE AS A PRIORITY FOR MY
ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIA DID NOT
RESOLVE THE INSURANCE CRISIS
THIS YEAR AND TEMPORARY
MORATORIUMS IS ALSO NOT A
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION EITHER.
BUT WHAT CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND
RANCHERS NEED IS AVAILABILITY
AND CURRENTLY THAT IS SOMETHING
WE DON'T HAVE. THE
AFFORDABILITY OF INSURANCE AND
POLICY TERMINATIONS HAVE BEEN
PROBLEMATIC AS WELL AS HAVE.
WE'VE BEEN INFORMED BY OUR
MEMBERS THAT PREMIUMS HAVE
INCREASED FROM 800-023-6000
DOLLARS ON A POLICY HOLDER.
MEANWHILE SPECIALLY FOR THOSE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NAPA
CINEMA EL DORADO CALAVERAS
PLASTER AS WELL AS AN EVENT
SHASTA. POLICIES ARE TERMINATED
ENTIRELY DUE TO WILDFIRE RISKS.
AS FAR AS PERSONAL SAFETY. THE
SARS PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
DOWNS CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
HAS BEEN FORCED TO BEAR THE
BRUNT OF WILDFIRE MITIGATION
EFFORTS SUCH AS PSP SHUTDOWNS.
INCREASING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS TO BE A
100% CLEAR THESE ARE NECESSARY
PROTOCOLS VALUABLE TOOLS TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES. WHILE
P. S. P. SHUT DOWNS WAS
CONDUCTED ON A MUCH MORE
LIMITED SCALE AND DURATION THIS
YEAR IT CREATES ADDED
UNCERTAINTIES FOR AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS. IN THE P. S. P.
EVENTS OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FARM BUREAU MEMBERS ON THE
NORTH COAST FOUND THEMSELVES OF
ELECTRICITY FOR FIVE DAYS OR
MORE. FOR ANNA **** AGO FARMER-
IN MENDOCINO AND DAIRY OPERATOR
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
THERE WAS NO BACKUP POWER FOR
HER MILKING OPERATION NO POWER
TO RUN THE MILKING EQUIPMENT.
IT ALSO IS ALSO NO POWER FORK
IS A ALSO MEANT NO POWER FOR
HER- MILK TANKS IN HER COLD
STORAGE FOR FIVE DAYS SHE
PUMPED AND DUMPED. IT'S
DEVASTATING FOR THESE
OPERATIONS THAT ALREADY OPERATE
ON THIN FINANCIAL MARGINS. SB
SHUTDOWNS ADVANCE ALSO PREVENT
FARMERS AND RANCHERS FROM BEING
ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
PROPERTIES AND NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES. THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MARIA FIRE IN VENTURA
COUNTY IS ONE PRIME EXAMPLE.
JOHN GREATER HONOR GREATER
FARMING COMPANY WHICH MANAGES
RANCHO TRES LOMAS FOR
PARTNERSHIP NEAR SO MUCH
CALIFORNIA HAD APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FIVE ACRES OF MATURE
AVOCADO TREES DESTROYED. AND
APPROXIMATELY TWO ACRES OF
NEWLY PLANTED LEMONS. DUE TO
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON'S- PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT DOWN PRACTICE THEY HAD NOT
BEEN ABLE TO IRRIGATE THE TREES
BEFORE THE FIRE STARTED WHICH
WOULD HAVE WHAT OF THE SOIL AND
LEAF LITTER. POTENTIALLY
SUPPRESSING THE FIRE SPREAD.
FURTHER DUE TO THE POWER SHUT
DOWN DURING THE FIRE THEY WERE
NOT ABLE TO FILL THEIR OWN
WATER TRUCKS AND STOP THE
SPREAD THE FIRE NOR THE ABLE TO
SATISFY THEIR QUEST TO FIRE
OFFICIALS. WHO WHO DESIRED
ADDITIONAL WATER FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL WATER WELLS WHEN
IT WAS OVER FARM LOSSES APPROX.
TOTALED APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN IT COMES
AMENDED BENJAMIN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES
CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND RANCHERS
CONTINUE TO FACE ANOTHER
CHALLENGE OVERLY AGGRESSIVE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT GOALS
FROM THE UTILITIES. WHILE THE
STATE HAS FORCED UTILITIES TO
FOCUS EFFORTS ON MITIGATING
WILDFIRE RISK THEIR FOCUS
CONTINUES TO BE MISPLACED.
IGNITION FROM THESE WILDFIRES
IS NOT DUE TO A TRANSMISSION OR
DISTRIBUTION LINE COMING INTO
CONTACT WITH AN- ALMOND TREE.
YET SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SB
NINE OH ONE THOUSANDS OF TREES
HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM SHE GO
TO BAKERSFIELD TO ENSURE SAFETY
AND RELIABILITY OF ELECTRICAL
SERVICE. MEANWHILE WE STILL
HAVE THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE WILD URBAN
INTERFACE. AND HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY AREAS OF CALIFORNIA AT
GREATER RISK OF POTENTIAL
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE. THESE
FIRES ARE NOT STARTING IN
AGRICULTURAL ORCHARDS BUT OUR
ORCHARDS CONTINUE TO BE STUMPED
SO THAT VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
GOALS CAN BE ATTAINED WITHOUT
NECESSARILY DECREASING WILDFIRE
RISK. IN A FEW MINUTES YOU ALSO
HEAR TESTIMONY FROM DR DAVE
DALY. HIS STORY COULD EASILY BE
REPLICATED IN ANY COMMUNITY
LOCATED WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA FACES ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES FROM THESE WILDFIRES
ONE HAS. ONE HAS BEEN ACTUALLY
NEGLECTED AND THAT INVOLVES
PROTECTION OR EVACUATION OF
LIVESTOCK FROM A WILDFIRE. OUR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS NEED THE
ABILITY TO CROSS INTO
EVACUATION ZONES TO RELOCATE
IMPERILED ANIMALS. THIS
SHOULDN'T A DISCUSSION NOT
ALLOWING US TO DO SO IS
CONDEMNING OUR ANIMALS TO DEATH
AND POTENTIAL'S POTENTIAL
SUFFERING IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES WE HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE WE CAN SAFELY
HUMANELY AND EFFICIENTLY
TRANSPORT OUR ANIMALS TO
SAFETY. HIRED VENDORS WORKING
FOR CAL FIRE OR THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE ON ANY ACTIVE
WILDLAND FIRE INCLUDE WATER
TENDER OPERATORS HEAVY
EQUIPMENT. OPERATORS THOSE ARE
OPERATORS TRUE BUS DRIVERS TO
CHAINSAW OPERATORS ALL REQUIRED
TO COMPLETE THE FIRE LINE
SAFETY AWARENESS COURSE I WANT
AT A ONE DAY EIGHT HOUR COURSE
OF INSTRUCTION. GIVE US THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY WE'RE
PROFESSIONAL JUST LIKE THOSE
VENDORS ALLOW US TO TAKE A
CERTIFICATION COURSE RELATIVE
TO WILDLAND FIRE SAFETY SO THAT
WE CAN BE CERTIFIED TO WORK
WITH IN AN EVACUATION ZONE. TO
SAFELY RELOCATE OR TEND TO OUR
LIVESTOCK. IF I COULD ON MY
CONCLUDING REMARKS THANK YOU
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF MY
ORGANIZATION. I THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU THIS AFTERNOON.
CALIFORNIA HAS FACED
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES IN
TWENTY TWENTY. AS HAVE ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT WE MUST REMAIN
COMMITTED TO FINDING SOLUTIONS
WELL BOND FUNDS GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS ANOTHER REVENUES ARE
CERTAINLY HELPFUL IT'S NOT THE
PANACEA THE STATE NEEDS
STRUCTURAL REGULATORY CHANGES
TO MAKE MEANINGFUL PROGRESS IN
TREATING APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
ONE MILLION ACRES IDENTIFIED.
BY CAL VTP. CALIFORNIA HAS A
GOAL TO INCREASE THE PACE AND
SCALE OF AGITATION TREATMENTS
AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES PER YEAR. ON NON FEDERAL
LANDS TO BE TREATED TO FULLY
TREAT TWENTY ONE MILLION ACRES
OF LAND AT A GOAL OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES PER YEAR
IT'LL TAKE FORTY TWO YEARS.
CALIFORNIA MUST DO BETTER AND
MUST BE MORE EFFICIENT. MAKE NO
MISTAKE CALIFORNIA IS PLAYING
CATCH UP TO A SITUATION THAT
HAS BEEN WORSENING FOR DECADES.
AND HAS BEEN EXASPERATED BY
DROUGHT DISEASE. AND EVEN
CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK YOU. MR
HASN'T REALLY APPRECIATE- THE
TESTIMONY AT THE OF THE PANEL
WE HAVE QUESTIONS WILL COME
BACK TO BACK UP. THANK YOU.
LIKE TO INVITE ONCE WE- DO
SANITATION PROTOCOLS I'D LIKE
TO INVITE OUR NEXT PANELIST TO
SPEAK MISTER EDDIE CAMPOS FROM
NO BOUNDARIES FARM BELIEVE HE'S
GONNA BE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON. AND. MISTER CAMPUS WHEN
YOU'RE READY. AND YOU HAVE A
CHOICE YOU COULD JUSTIFY THEIR
STANDING OR HERE ON THE TABLE.
OKAY. GOOD THANK YOU MY NAME IS
EDDIE CAMPOS- I AM A HEMP
FARMER FROM MY SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA I OWN A FARM CALLED
NO BOUNDARIES FARM WERE FAMILY
OWNED WERE LOCALLY GROWN THE
REASON I GOT INVOLVED IN THIS
INDUSTRY- I HAD A SICK MOTHER
WHO WAS GIVEN A FEW MONTHS TO
LIVE AND NOW THE DOCTOR SAID
THERE WAS NOTHING ELSE THEY
COULD DO. I DIDN'T BELIEVE WHAT
THEY SAID SO I GOT MY MOM TAKEN
CBD OILS AND ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT NATURAL STUFF. I'VE
FOUGHT AGAINST THEM DOCTORS AND
MY MOTHER- END UP LIVING AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN MONTHS.
FROM THIS PRODUCT- THIS IS MADE
FROM HEMP SO THE PRODUCT IS
AMAZING SO WHAT IT DID IT FORCE
ME INTO. GETTING THE FARM AND
GROWING MY OWN HOME BECAUSE I
WAS SO EXCITED ON THE MEDICINAL
SIDE OF WITH THIS. PRODUCT CAN
DO. UNFORTUNATELY ON AUGUST
SEVENTH OF TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY I LOST MY MOTHER.
SEVENTEEN MONTHS AFTER THE
DOCTOR SAID SHE HAD NO LONGER
TO LIVE. ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH OF
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY MY SON
TAPPED ME ON THE SHOULDER. AS
I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF A RE DOING
ONE OF OUR STRUCTURES TO HAVE
MY MOM SERVICES- MY SON TAPPED
ON THE SHOULDER AND SAID THAT.
CAN YOU LOOK OUT IN THAT FIELD
OUT THERE I LOOKED OUT THERE
AND I SEEN A FIRE STARTING THIS
IS WHAT TO THIRTY NINE IN THE
AFTERNOON ON SATURDAY.
SEPTEMBER FIFTH. I'M LIKE SON
EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE OKAY-
WE'RE JUST GOING TO CALL NINE
ONE ONE AND WE DON'T HAVE
NOTHING TO WORRY SO WE GUESS
ALL WENT BACK IN. TO DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING- HEMP FARMING. ALL
ROUND THREE THIRTY THE FIRE GOT
BIGGER FOUR THIRTY I GOT
BIGGER. WE HAD NO AIR SUPPORT
WE HAD NO GROUND SUPPORT IT WAS
MY SON. MYSELF IN A COUPLE OF
HIS FRIENDS. AND OUR MINDSET
ORIGINALLY IS THEY'RE GONNA
HELP US WE GOT AIR SUPPORT
GROUND SUPPORT ONCE WE REALIZED
THERE WEREN'T COMING. OUR WHOLE
MINDSET CHANGE WE HAD TRACTORS
ON THE PROPERTY. WE HAD
GENERATORS TO RUN OUR WELLS BUT
WE DIDN'T GRAB NONE OF THAT
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT THEY WERE
COMMON. GOT INTO SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT O'CLOCK AT NIGHT. NOW
IT'S FIVE SIX HOURS LATER THE
FIRES COMING DOWN THE HILL-
IT'S JUST TAKEN US OVER SO WE
START FROM PATENT WE COULD
ADDED THERE- AS WE WATCH MY
SON'S HOUSE BURN THE TWO STORY
HOUSE BURNED OUR WHOLE HEMP
FARM BURNED RIGHT IN FRONT OF
OUR OWN ICE. IT'S A DEVASTATING
EXPERIENCE AND SOMETHING I HOPE
NONE OF YOU EXPERIENCE- AND
IT'S ALWAYS IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO SOMEBODY ELSE BUT IT
HAPPENED TO US. THANK GOD WE
WERE ABLE TO HELP SAVE A BUNCH
OF ANIMALS ON THE NEIGHBOR'S
PROPERTY. WE WERE ABLE TO- GET
SOME OF OUR PERSONAL ITEMS BUT
NOT MANY OUT OF THERE. AS WE
SEEN THIS FIRE COMING OVER THE
HILLS. IT'S JUST A- WHEN YOU
MAKE THAT NINE ONE ONE CALL YOU
NEVER WANT TO DO IT BUT WHEN
YOU FINALLY NEED IT WASN'T
AVAILABLE. HI LOST CLOSE TO A
MILLION A HALF TO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF STRUCTURES OF HAMP.
IT IS ALREADY HARD ENOUGH
INDUSTRY TO BE INVOLVEDIN.
FROM AS IT'S A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM RIGHT NOW- PEOPLE ARE
REALIZING THE BENEFITS OF THIS
PRODUCT NOT ONLY ON THE
BEAUTIFUL SIDE OF IT BUT ALSO.
TO HELP WITH DEFORESTATION AND
STUFF I THINK IT'S A GREAT
COMMODITY FOR US IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT BOTHERS ME HERE. AS
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY I PURCHASED
THIS FARM. I PAY MY TAXES. WHEN
I WANT TO GET INSURANCE I WAS
DENIED FROM INSURANCE I HAD
FOUR DIFFERENT BROKERS COME TO
THE PROPERTY. I ASKED HIM TO
ENSURE THE FARMS I GOT DENIED.
I ASKED HIM TO INSURE MY
STRUCTURE THEY SAID WELL YOUR
STRUCTURES ARE TOO OLD I SAID
WELL I BOUGHT THE FARM THEY
WERE ALREADY PERMITTED
STRUCTURES AND WE WENT AHEAD
AND DID OPERATIONS IN THE
STRUCTURE. WE ARE STILL DENIED
FROM INSURANCE THEN WE WENT
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA FAIR PLAN
AND WE WERE DENIED FROM THAT AS
WELL. SO AS I SPEAK FROM NO
BOUNDARIES FARM I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
OTHER FARMERS RANCHERS OUT
THERE. WHAT IT'S LIKE. TO TRY
TO GET THE MINDSET TO REBUILD.
WHO'S GOING TO HELP US IS THERE
MONEY AVAILABLE FOR US WE DON'T
KNOW- IT'S BEEN VERY
DEVASTATING FOR MYSELF FOR MY
FAMILY MOVING FORWARD- AND
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO ASK FOR
HELP. US FARMERS NEED INSURANCE
WE CAN'T DO THIS AGAIN WITHOUT
INSURANCE WITHOUT YOUR GUYS
HELP OUT THERE. RIGHT NOW THE
REMAINING PRODUCT THAT I HAD
LEFT I HAD TO MOVE DOWN TO
COLLECT TO GO TO A FRIEND'S
PLACE TO HELP DRY THE REMAINING
PRODUCT THAT I WAS ABLE TO
SALVAGE. SO I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE FARMERS TO LIST DO
SOMETHING. THANK YOU. MISTER
COUPLES REALLY APRECIATE- YOU
MAKING THE TIME- YOUR TESTIMONY
AND FOR SHARING YOUR STORY. AND
WE'LL RESERVE QUESTIONS AND
TELL ALL OF THE PRESENTERS OF
SPOKEN. NEXT SPEAKER LIKE TO
INVITE- WOULD BE DOCTOR DAVE
DALY THE RANCHER- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLE ASSOCIATION
BELIEVE HE HE'S HERE IN PERSON
SO- AGAIN MR DAILY YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME UP THESE CABLES
YOU CAN STAND AS FAR AS WELL.
AS. YEAH. YEAH ASSEMBLY. WHAT
AREA WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO DO THIS IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL TO ALL OF AGRICULTURE
IN CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA IN
GENERAL AND- I DON'T WANNA
SPEND TOO MUCH TIME ON PERSONAL
STORIES BUT I CERTAINLY HAVE
ONE AND PAST PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA CALLUM'S ASSOCIATION
BUT I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS
FOR A LONG TIME MY ENTIRE LIFE
FIFTH GENERATION. IN BUTTE
COUNTY SO I HAVE TO WATCH MY
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS AND JAMIE
JOE HANSON'S ONE OF THEM LEAVE
THE CAMPFIRE AND NOW THE NORTH
LIGHTNING COMPLEX WHICH STRUCK
ME VERY CLOSE TO HOME IN THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS I PROBABLY
HAD TEN TO FIFTEEN FIRES ON MY
VARIOUS PROPERTIES ON MY
BRANCHES UP BUT IN THAT CASE.
NONE HAS BEEN AS DESTRUCTIVE
AND EACH TIME IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE GETTING TO A GREATER
DESTRUCTION AS THESE FIRES
ARRIVED AND I'M REALLY NOT HERE
WORRY ABOUT WHY IT'S LET'S DO
SOMETHING AND IN THIS CASE THEN
THE NORTH LIGHTNING COMPLEX
WHICH WE CALL THE BARE FIRE THE
TIME CAME SO QUICKLY THROUGH
OUR MOUNTAIN RANGE. THAT WITHIN
ABOUT TWELVE HOURS A DAY OVER
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES AND
THAT INCLUDED- THE MAJORITY MY
CAL HEARD ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED
COWS AND THEIR CALVES WERE
KILLED IN THE FIRE- THAT IS NOT
ALL- PRIVATE LAND IT'S HALF
FEDERAL AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS ISSUE IS
CERTAINLY NOT JUST A STATE
ISSUE IT'S A FEDERAL ISSUE AS
WELL IT'S THE MANAGEMENT OF OUR
NATIONAL FORESTS I HAVE PERMITS
ON THE PLUMAS NATIONAL FOREST
AS WELL AS LEASED LAND WITH
SIERRA PACIFIC INTERNATIONAL A
GREAT LOGGING TIMBER FIRM THAT
I'VE WORKED WITH FOR DECADES.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE
ALL THAT LAND WAS GONE IN ABOUT
TWELVE HOURS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS A CATTLEMAN TO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR SITUATION
TENDS TO BE A BIT DIFFERENT
THAN AS WE'VE HEARD FROM
VINEYARDS FOR EXAMPLE WHICH ARE
HIGH DOLLAR- PER ACRE BUT IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE IS NOT
ONLY US THAT SUMMER AND THE
LOSS OF TEMPER IT'S THE
WILDLIFE IN ITS ENVIRONMENT.
THAT PARTICULAR FIRE IS BETWEEN
THE SOUTH FORK IN THE MIDDLE
FORK OF THE FEATHER. RIVER
WHICH IS A DRAINAGE FOR LIKE
ORVILLE. HE WHAT'S GOING TO
THIS YEAR IT DOES RAIN. LET'S
GO TO HAPPEN TO LIKE OR BILL
THAT JUST IN. ME PER. BUT
IMPACTS THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
FRANKLY THE ENTIRE STATE WE SEE
THAT- I WE HAD A SMALL RAIN
YESTERDAY AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
WITH THAT RAIN. WE GET ONE OF
THE MAJOR ONES LIKE ORACLE'S
GOING TO BE A DIFFERENT PLACE.
IN TERMS OF POLLUTION IN THE
RUNOFF THAT'S GOING TO OCCUR
THERE. SO IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE OUR CATTLE WERE. KILLED IN
SOME PRETTY HORRIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES- IT'S DIFFICULT
TO WATCH. AND TO SEE WE HAD TO
GAIN ACCESS WHICH WAS DIFFICULT
TO DO BUT WHEN WE DID. WE ARE
STILL AN ACTIVE FIRE ZONE. AND
WHAT WE WOULD FIND WERE CATTLE
THAT WERE BURNT TRYING TO GET
AWAY- AND SOME OF THE PICTURES-
RIFIC YOU MAY HAVE SEEN SOME OF
THOSE WERE PUBLISHED. BUT WHEN
YOU WALK UP ON A GROUP OF EIGHT
CHAO'S WITH THREE BABY CAST BUT
WHEN I REPEAT ROUTINE AND
BURNT- BEYOND RECOGNITION. MY
DAUGHTER IS A VETERINARIAN MY
SON'S SOLD MY YOUNG SON SOLDIER
THE OLDEST ONE RANCHERS WITH ME
ALL THREE WERE HELPING. AND
WE'RE HOME AT THE TIME THEY GOT
THERE SOON AS THEY COULD. TO
HAVE AN ACTIVE FIRE IN THE
BOTTOM OF CREEK. AND CAL WITH
THEIR LEGS BURNED OFF. I'M
SORRY TO BE GRAPHIC IN STILL
LIFE. AND MICE EUTHANIZE- AND
HE WAS GOING TO LOOK FOR OTHER
CATTLE OF THE TIME SEE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE THERE
IT'S SO SMOKY. MY DAUGHTER SAW
A CATHOLIC INSIDE OF HER.
INDEED AN EMERGENCY C. SECTION
WAS ONLY FIVE MINUTES TOO LATE.
THAT'S A RIFIC. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH AGRICULTURE
IN SO IT IS AN ECONOMIC LOSS
AND I GET THAT BUT THIS IS A
LOSS TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA. I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO EMPHASIZE.
THIS IS NOT A LEFT AND RIGHT
ISSUE. AT ALL. THIS IS
CALIFORNIA ISSUE AND WE NEED TO
WORK ON IT. FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE. AND I THINK TOO
OFTEN WE GET INTO CAMPS. IS
THIS CLIMATE CHANGES AS
MANAGEMENT I DON'T CARE. DO
SOMETHING. RIGHT I THINK
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
DIFFERENCES AND WHAT I HAVE
SEEN OVER TIME HE MY PARTICULAR
INSTANCE. I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER THE PRESCRIBED BURN
CONTROLLED BURNS WE CALL THEM.
OR AN ACTIVE TOOL. THEY WERE
TOLD THAT WE COULD USE IN THE
WINTER TIME. AND THE RIGHT
CONDITIONS TO REDUCE FUEL LOADS
WE STOPPED DOING THAT. TO ANY
DEGREE PROBABLY THIRTY YEARS
AGO AND EVERY YEAR IS LASTIN
PART THAT IS A REGULATORY
ISSUES THAT PREVENT US FROM
DOING SO. I WOULD DEARLY LOVE
TO SEE- NOT A CHALLENGE
BETWEEN. CAL FIRE AND AIR
RESOURCES BOARD OF WHEN WE CAN
BURN A WIN WE CAN'T BURN. I'D
LIKE TO SEE SOMEBODY SAY OKAY
IT'S THE WINTER TIME MAYBE
THERE'S AN AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGE BUT IT'S NOT NEARLY
AS SIGNIFICANT AS THE ONE WE'RE
GOING TO GET IF IT BURNS FOR
TWO MONTHS IN THE SUMMER. I'D
LIKE TO SEE SOMEONE WHO HAD THE
AUTHORITY IN THE STATE AT SOME
LEVEL TO SAY. WE'RE GONNA MAKE
THIS WORK WE'RE GONNA DO MORE
CONTROL FINE FUEL REDUCTION FOR
FUEL REDUCTION IN THE WINTER
TIME. THAT WILL BE DIFFICULT TO
DO BECAUSE CITIZENRY
APPROPRIATELY SO ARE PETRIFIED
OF FIRE. AND THE FUEL LOADS ARE
pARE AFRAID OF LIABILITY IF I DO
CONTROL OVER WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IF IT HAPPENS TO ESCAPE
WE REALLY NEED AND I TRUST THE
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA HELP US
IN THIS. THE EXPERTS ON THE
GROUND TO SAY WE CAN BURN AT
THIS TIME WE'VE GOT TO REDUCE
FUEL LOADS. SECONDARILY GRAZING
CAN PLAY A ROLE IN THAT.
SCENARIO INFINE FUEL REDUCTION
THERE'S BEEN SOME RECENT
RESEARCH FROM DEBURAU WITH UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION WHICH
SHOWS THE AMOUNT OF FINE FUELS
A RENEWED BIKE RACING. I THINK
IT'S KIND OF. ACTUALLY I JUST I
DON'T KNOW IF I WERE USE WHERE
HUMOR IS MAYBE A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING ALL OF A SUDDEN
GRAZING REGRET SHEEP AND GOATS
IN TOWN IT'S REALLY COOL. AFTER
WE ELIMINATED IT FOR THE LAST
FIFTY TO SIXTY YEARS. YOU KNOW
WHEN WE KNEW IT WAS COOL BEFORE
BUT NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S
LIKE WELL WE CAN REDUCE FUEL
LOADS IF WE RAISE WE KNEW THAT.
AND WE MADE IT SO HARD TO DO
THAT PEOPLE ARE UNWILLING TO
TAKE THAT RISK A LIABILITY
ECONOMICS THE CHALLENGES. SO IF
I HAD TO REQUEST AND I REALIZE
THESE ARE NOT ONES THAT THIS
ONE COMMITTEE BY ITSELF WOULD
BE ABLE TO DO. BUT ONE IS WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT PERSON
AT. THE ABILITY TO USE
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY THAT'S GOING TO GIVE US
LIABILITY PROTECTION TO DO SO
WE NEED TO HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH CAL FIRE. THAT ALLOW US TO
BURN EVEN THOUGH AIR RESOURCES.
BOARD SAY HAND MAYBE A LITTLE
QUESTIONABLE TODAY. THEN WE
MISS OUT OPPORTUNITY. AND THEN
WE BURN TOWN. A CAMPFIRE.
PARADISE EIGHTY NINETY PEOPLE
BURNED. RIGHT BERRY CREEK THE
LITTLE TOWN. IN OUR AREA
FOURTEEN PEOPLE DIED JUST ABOUT
A MONTH AGO. IT'S NOT ABOUT ME
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT AGRICULTURE
THIS IS SOMETHING FAR LARGER
THAN- I THINK WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AGREE ON THAT WE
HAVE AN ISSUE IT'S CLIMATE
CHANGE IT'S A MANAGE BUT IT'S
BOTH LET'S PUT OVER OUR QUIT
ARGUING ABOUT WHICH IT IS AND
JUST DO SOMETHING THAT'S
EFFECTIVE. MY COURAGE OF IT AT
WHATEVER LEVEL YOU CAN DO IS TO
REALLY TALK TO PEOPLE AND SAY
PRESCRIBED FIRE NEEDS TO BE A
TOOL LET'S DO IT LET'S USE
GRAZING ON STATE FEDERAL AND
MUNICIPAL LANDS INSTEAD OF
PUTTING BARRIERS IN TO DO THAT
I THINK IT GIVES US SOME
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS DALY WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE- ALL OF YOU YOU'RE A
INFORMATION VERY FORMATIVE- AND
I'M SURE WEMAY HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- THANK YOU. AT THE
CONCLUSION. NEXT PANELIST ALSO
HERE IN PERSON IS A CRYSTAL
KRAUSE PRESIDENT OF THE SONOMA
COUNTY WINE GROWERS. CREWS I
APOLOGIZE I WAS JUST CORRECTED
IT'S CHRIS- CRUCE. THANK YOU
MISTER LIVING. I KNOW. I DON'T
REMEMBER FOR LIKE EIGHT YEARS.
BROWN I DON'T KNOW IF. YEAH. IT
GETS MESSED UP ALL THE TIME SO
NO WORRIES HAVE A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR RIVAS AND
FELLOW AG COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK I'M STILL
GETTING USED TO THE MASK SO-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING THIS
AFTERNOON- UNFORTUNATELY OUR
OUR LOCAL CINEMA COUNTY
COMMUNITY AND FARMERS HAVE
BEEN- DEVASTATED BY THREE
WILDFIRES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND SO I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT SORT OF THE IMPACT
TO OUR FARMERS THE IMPACT TO
OUR FRMWORKERS AND KIND OF THE
WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR US
WHERE WE COULD USE SOME HELP
AND- I PERSONALLY KNOW THE
DEVASTATION CAUSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I LOST MY
HOME IN THE TUBBS FIRE SO. THIS
IS NEAR AND DEAR TO ME AS WELL
AS HOW DO WE WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE CINEMA COUNTY YET- AND
CALIFORNIA A BETTER PLACE TO
LIVE AND WORK AND HAVE MORE-
PREDICTABILITY IN OUR FUTURE AS
A AS A STATE AND A COMMUNITY
CENTER I DO WANT TO START TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT FOR
REPRESENT AND GIVE SOME CONTEXT
ABOUT WHAT FARMING LOOKS LIKE
IN CINEMA COUNTY FOR
WINEGROWERS WITH ABOUT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED GRAPE GROWERS IN CINEMA
COUNTY AND ALSO MARIN- OUR
LOCAL GRAPE GROWERS FAMILY
FARMERS MULTI GENERATIONAL AND
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SMALL BUSINESS
MEN AND WOMEN SO ABOUT 80% OF
OUR LOCAL VINEYARDS ARE LESS
THAN A HUNDRED ACRES. 40% LESS
THAN TWENTY ACRES SO ONE AT
LOSS OF CROP ONE YEAR CAN
REALLY PUT SOME OF OUR FARMERS
REALLY ON THE FRENCH OF WHETHER
THERE CAN CONTINUE TO FARM
WHETHER THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
KEEP OUR FARMS IN AG LAND WHICH
WE KNOW IS SO IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY FOR THEIR LIVELIHOOD BUT
REALLY FOR THE LANDSCAPE OF
CALIFORNIA- THE ECONOMY AND YOU
KNOW THE FUTURE FAMILY. FAMILY
BUSINESSES SO. EACH OUR FIRE
SYSTEM REALLY DE WITH THE REAL
DIFFERENT AND- YOU KNOW TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT WAS URBAN
FIRE- YOU KNOW A LOT OF OUR
GROUPS WERE IN MOST OF OUR
GROUPS WE- WE HAD ABOUT 95% OF
HARVEST DONE- BY THE- OCTOBER
DATE WHEN THE TUBBS FIRE IN THE
SEVENTEEN FIRES HIT. SO WE
DIDN'T SEE THAT IMPACT REALLY
TO OUR VINEYARDS INTERCROPPING
IN FACT. IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE HEARD OF THE BENEFIT OF
OUR AG LANDS ARE WORKING LANDS
SLOWING AND STOPPING FIRES.
THERE WAS ACTUALLY SOME GOOD
NEWS IN THE SENSE OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH AGRICULTURE.
UNFORTUNATE THAT TIME WE HAD A
FOURTEEN FARMWORKERS LOSE THEIR
HOME SO. IN THE OTHER WORK THAT
I DO RUNNING THE CINEMA COUNTY
GRIPPERS FOUNDATION- WE WORK TO
SUPPORT THE SIXTY TWO HUNDRED
OF FULL TIME VINEYARD WORKERS.
THAT WORK IN CINEMA COUNTY THE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED SEASONAL
VINEYARD WORKERS. I'M AS WELL
AS OTHER FARMWORKERS SO. IN
THAT CASE WE YOU- SUPPORTED US
FOURTEEN FARMWORKER FAMILIES BY
PAYING RENT FOR TWO YEARS. WE
BOUGHT THREE R. V.'S FOR
TEMPORARY HOUSING. TO TRY TO
GET THROUGH THAT SO IT'S AN
URBAN FIRE. INTO DOESN'T
EIGHTEEN WE HAD THE KINCAID
FIRE NOT ONLY DID WE GET
IMPACTED BY THE POWER SHUT
OFFS. BUT REALLY THE NORTHERN
PART OF CINEMA COUNTY WAS
LARGELY IMPACTED IN OUR
FARMING. AGAIN LATE IN THE YEAR
END OF OCTOBER NOVEMBER SELENA
HARVEST. SO WE'RE ABOUT 90% OF
OUR CROPS IN IT BUT OUR OUR
CABERNET SO YOUNG GROWERS. LIKE
OUR NEIGHBORS IN NAPA VALLEY
FELT A BIG IMPACT TO WHAT THAT
HAPPENED. UNFORTUNATELY FOR
FARMWORKERS WE ACTUALLY HAD
IMPACT OVER A THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS AND I SEE IMPACT.
WASN'T WE ONLY HAVE FIVE WHOSE
HOUSES WHICH I GUESS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION FROM
SEVENTEEN. BUT WE SAW A LOT OF
LOSS OF THEIR INCOME FROM
EVACUATIONS FROM LOSS OF WORK
BECAUSE OF THE FIRE BECAUSE OF
HOW MUCH TIME THEY HAVE TO
SPEND AWAY FROM THEIR HOME.
BECAUSE OF HOW LONG THE CAN
CADE FIRE AND THE SUBSEQUENT
EVACUATIONS HOW WIDESPREAD.
THEY WERE. I IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND THEN TWENTY TWENTY HAPPENED.
I THINK WHEN WE THOUGHT WE- HAD
SEEN IT ALL WE HAD. JUST BARELY
SEE IN THE BEGINNING OF WHAT
THE IMPACT COULD BE TO
AGRICULTURE. AND OUR FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. SO IN TWENTY TWENTY-
PART OF THE ISSUE IS NOT THAT
IT JUST HAPPENED IN CINEMA
COUNTY AND NOT THEN ARE AND THE
NORTH BAY. IS THAT WE SAW THIS
YOU KNOW. TRUMP TRAGEDY AND-
FROM ALL ACROSS THE STATE
DIFFERENT WINE REGIONS. WHICH
REALLY EXASPERATED THE ISSUES
FOR A LOCAL GRAPE GROWERS AND
OUR VENDOR PARTNERS. SO TWENTY
TWENTY- YOU KNOW THE ABOUT
1415% OF OUR CROP IS IN WHEN
THE FIRST START FIRE STARTED IN
AUGUST. AND SO WE SAW SO MANY
OF OUR CROPS OF IMPACT. BY
SMOKE EXPOSURE. AND ONE OF THE
BIG ISSUES WAS NOT GOING TO GET
THE TESTING DONE IN TIME NOT
HAVING ENOUGH TESTING
RESOURCES. WE JUST AGREE OF
COURSE TO- TO- TO INFORM US
ABOUT WHAT THEY THOUGHT THEIR
HARVEST REJECT- CROP WOULD BE.
WELL GONE HARVESTED WILL BE
REJECTED. AND THEY SAID ABOUT
25230% OF WHAT THAT EQUATES TO
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND TONS OF
GRAPES IN SONOMA COUNTY WENT.
ON HARVESTED. OUT OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND TON
AVERAGE CROP. THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT OUR LOCAL FARMERS AND
THAT IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE DIFFERENT VARIETIES THAT
DIDN'T GET- HARVESTED. THAT'S
JUST LOCALLY IN THE AGAIN THESE
ARE SMALL. BUSINESSMEN AND
WOMEN. ARE ARE BARELY YOU KNOW
KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON ON THEIR
FARM OR TRYING TO EMPLOYEE. THE
FARMERS. WITH ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FORMER FOR FAMILIES IMPACTED-
AND- AGAIN TO OF OUR LOCAL
FARMER FAMILIESLOST THEIR
HOMES. AND INTO TWENTY TWENTY
FIRES. WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS
THE TRICKLE DOWN IMPACT SO WE
KNOW DURING HARVEST- ARE
FARMWORKERS OUR VINEYARD
WORKERS ARE MAKING. YOU KNOW
THIRTY DOLLARS PLUS AN HOUR
BECAUSE WE CHANGED TO A PIECE
RATE. SO WE KNOW A LOT OF THEM.
LOST THAT WORK FOR THOSE COUPLE
OF WEEKS SORTS TYPICALLY WOULD
BE THAT THE HIGHLIGHT OF THEIR
SEASON IN TERMS OF FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. SORT TRYING TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THAT.
AND WE STILL DON'T KNOW WE KNOW
IT WAS NOT HARVESTED BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TRICKLE
DOWN IMPACT WILL BE. OF OUR
VENDORS NUMBERS WORK TOGETHER
TO BRING IN GRAPES. IN MAY NOT
OF AND- SUBSEQUENTLY CRUSH RIND
IT MAY NEVER OR GET MADE INTO.
AND SO AS WE LOOK AHEAD TO- IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW WHAT CAN WE
DO. ONE WHEN WE NEED HELP WITH
ALL OF THE INSURANCE ISSUES IN
THE LAND MANAGEMENT THAT. MY
PREVIOUS PALACES SPOKEN ABOUT
SO I WON'T TOUCH ON KNOWS. THE
TO SPECIFIC AREAS THAT ARE
CONCERNING. IS THE FUTURE OF
GETTING US TESTING FASTER MORE
AVAILABILITY. SO WE HAD SO MUCH
UNPREDICTABILITY AND WHAT WAS
HARVESTED- AND WHETHER THOSE
GROUPS ACTUALLY BE MADE INTO
WINE JUST BECAUSE WE COULDN'T
GET GOOD TEST RESULTS BACK. IN
TIME. SO WE TOOK A LOT OF RISK
ACROSS GOT LEFT ON THE VINE
BECAUSE WONDERS DID WANT TO
TAKE THAT RISK SUCH A FINANCIAL
IMPACT TO THE FARMERS. AS WELL
AS A FINANCIAL IMPACT TO THE
FARMWORKERS. THE OTHER THING
THAT'S CONCERNING IS OUR
GROWERS AND MOST OF THEIR
CONTRACTS. ARE BASED ON WHAT
THE AVERAGE ON CROP RATE IS IN
THE CAR AND THE ANNUAL CROP
REPORT REQUEST REPORT. WE HAVE
NO IDEA HOW THAT IS GOING TO BE
TO TERM THIS YEAR WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WINERIES ARE GONNA REPORT
TO WE KNOW A LOT OF GROUPS
DIDN'T GET HARVESTED. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE VALUE WOULD BE OF
THOSE GROUPS THAT DID GET
HARVESTED BECAUSE A LOT OF THAT
WAS A NEGOTIATION. CROP-
DEDUCTIONS TAKEN. IT'S WE DON'T
KNOW THIS IS A CDFA THING WE'RE
REALLY NEED HELP AND I THINK
WORKING WITH CALLS AT THE STATE
LEVEL THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ONE GROUP
GROWERS. TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
A GOOD BASELINE. BECAUSE ARE A
LOT OF AGAIN ACROSS OUR OUR-
OUR CONTRACTS ARE BASED ON WHAT
THAT AVERAGE SO THE GIRLS GET
PAID ON AN- AVERAGE PINO
NORFOLK ON PRICE. PER TON ON
AVERAGE CABERNET SAUVIGNON
PRICE FOR TIME. AND THE USE THE
PREVIOUS YEAR'S BASELINE.
THERE'S GONNA BE COMPLETELY
UPSIDE DOWN I'M NOT HEARING OF
ANYONE THAT'S FIGURED OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO NAVIGATE THIS
YEAR SO THAT IS ONE OF OUR BIG
CONCERNS. AGAIN IN ADDITION TO
SORT OF LOOKING AHEAD SO. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING PART OF
THE SOLUTION I THINK LIKE
EVERYONE ASIDE- WE'RE REALLY
THANKFUL TO- HAVE YOU CHAIR
RIVAS- GOING AROUND THE STATE
AND VISITING AND MEETING WITH
OUR OUR LOCAL FARMERS. AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SUPPORT
AND WE NEED TO BRING AN END. TO
THE WILD FIRES WE NEED TO HAVE
BETTER LAND MANAGEMENT AND
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. NOT ONLY
OUR GRAPE GROWERS AND FARMERS
BUT OUR FARMWORKERS. WITHOUT
ALL. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. MISTER REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU BEING HERE AND-
I HAVE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OUR NEXT PANELIST TO
SPEAK WILL BE JOINING US- OVER
THE PHONE IT'S A WHOLE. MUZA
RIEGO SAYS ANA STASIO- WITH
BRISA DE ANO RANCH A MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR A CALL. HELLO THIS IS
CALLED CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME YES
WE CAN CALL. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THAT IS MY NAME
IS CALLED LAST WEEK WAS GOING
TO STOP YOU- I'M ONE OF THREE
OWNERS OPERATORS ARE PLEASED
AND ANNUAL RANCH WE ARE A-
SMALL EIGHT ACRE ORGANIC FARM-
INVESTOR CALIFORNIA- THERE WERE
ONLY A LITTLE OVER AN HOUR FROM
HERE JUST GO WERE OF VERY REAL
COMMUNITY. I'M IN A VERY TIGHT
KNIT COMMUNITY- IT WE WERE HIT
BY THE- FIRE STEMMING FROM THE
CD YOU LETTING COMPLEX BACK IN
MID AUGUST- WITH THE FIRE- IN
OUR FARM. ON AUGUST TWENTIETH
OF THIS YEAR- WE HAVE- WERE AS
GOOD AS A SMALL FARM AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU YOU HAVING US
HERE I JUST BECAUSE AS- A SMALL
FARMERS EXPERIENCE THIS- I
THINK EXPERIENCE THAT'S MAYBE-
IT IN A BIT OF THE UNIQUE WAY-
IN DIFFERENT RESPECTS ARE R. G.
AS I MENTIONED BEING A VERY
REAL COMMUNITY- IT. DID NOT GET
A LOT OF TENSION DURING THE
FIRES IN TERMS OF A RESPONSE
FROM- IF TRUMP FROM
FIREFIGHTING FORCES I DO TOO SO
MANY FIRES GOING IN DIFFERENT
PARTS- YOUR ONGOING DIFFERENT
PARTS THE STATE- WE- ENDED UP-
HAVING TO. DEAL WITH A LOT OF
THE ISSUE OURSELVES- AS WITH
THE CASE ARE FORMED IN A LOT OF
OUR FARMS OUR COMMUNITY- WE
ENDED UP- SIGNIFIERS- IT
STARTED UP IN THE MOUNTAINS
ABOVE OUR FARM. I ON AUGUST
SIXTEENTH- FROM LIGHTNING
STRIKES THAT THAT STRUCK THERE
AND- THE FIRE KIND OF CREPT
DOWN THE MOUNTAINS TOWARDS OUR
FARM. OVER THE COURSE NEXT
THREE DAYS. DURING THOSE THREE
DAYS WE WERE ABLE TO- PREPARE
TO A LARGE DEGREE- WE ARE ABLE
TO CUT FIRE BREAKS. WE'RE ABLE
TO- USER ADDITIONS SYSTEM TO
SPRAY DOWN. A- CAL HOSED DOWN
ESPECIALLY THE PRIMER OF THOSE
HEARTBREAKS- TO ENSURE. THAT
THE- ARE WE NOT WE'RE NOT GONNA
COME WITHIN THE PER- WE SPEND
CENTURY DAYS DO THIS NON- MANY
OF OUR NEIGHBORS TO THE SIGN
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD AS WELL.
AND WE WERE VERY FORTUNATE THAT
THAT FROM THAT WORK AND ALSO
WORK OF BEING THERE THE DAY OF
THE FIRE TO CONFRONT THE FIRES
YOU CAN DAYS AFTER- THAT
EVERYTHING WITHIN. THE
PERIMETER THAT WE CREATED HELD
AND WAS OKAY. YOU GO TO OUR
HOMES OUR FIELD ALTHOUGH WE DID
LOSE A LOT OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE TOOLS EQUIPMENT.
THAT WERE OUTSIDE THAT
PERIMETER- AMOUNTING TO WHAT
WOULD BE ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR US- WHICH- FOR A
SMALL FARM LIKE OURS A SIZEABLE-
WE ENDED UP- WORKING A LOT OF
CAL FIRE IN THAT TIME PERIOD-
OFFICIALLY- OUR OUR REZONE WAS
FORCED TO EVACUATE AS WITH THE
CASE FOR MANY AREAS- BUT AS
THERE WERE SO MANY FIRES ON
GOING AT THE SAME TIME YOUR
STATE. A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
COMMUNITY RECOGNIZED THAT THERE
WERE NOT ENOUGH KALIFORNIA
RESOURCES TO BE DEDICATED TO A
REAL COMMUNITY LIKE OURS WE
JUST WEREN'T THAT MANY HOUSES
FOR PEOPLE IN THE AREA- WITH A
LOT MORE ATTENTION ARE BEING
FOCUSED. ELSEWHERE- KALIFORNIA-
THE FOLKS MAKE UP ARTWORK HERE-
FACT BY THE FIRED WITH US WERE
INCREDIBLE AND HER- CAN AND
YOUR EFFORTS- DAY WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SAVING A LOT OF
THE AREAS IN OUR COMMUNITY- BUT
I DO ONE THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO- DISTRESSED. IN TERMS
OF OUR EXPERIENCE WAS THAT
FOLKS ARE COMMITTEE WERE ALSO.
AB CREDIBLY NECESSARY- IN
SHAPING AROUND FARMS AND
RANCHES- WE DID SO BY
SUPPORTING CAL FIRE TO A LARGE
DEGREE WE WERE THE ONES OFTEN
USING ARE ARE USUALLY JUST ENDS
TO FILL UP THEIR WATER TANKS-
SO THEY COULDN'T THEY COULDN'T
RESPOND WATER MORE RAPIDLY- WE
WERE. KIND OF STARTING A SCOUTS
FOR CALIFORNIA AND SHOW THEM
WHERE THE FIRE WHICH WAS GOING
AND- AND WHAT STRUCTURE THEY
NEED TO BE AWARE OF- WE ALSO
WORK. ACTIVELY USING OUR
TRACTORS ARE EQUIPMENT. TO
CREATE FIREBREAKS- TO PULL OUT-
TREES FROM FROM AREAS AS WELL
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
CONTRACTOR DURING THE DAYS OF
THE FIRE IN THE DAYS AFTER-
JUST PHYSICALLY. YEAH HE
OUTRAGE FROM THE BASE WITH A
TRAINED TIED TO OUR TRACTOR- DO
YOU. TELL THOSE EFFORTS WE WERE
ABLE TO. SAVE OUR FARM AND- AND
ALSO A LOT OF OTHER FORMS IN
OUR COMMUNITY YOU'RE KIND OF
WORLD OF MUTUAL WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY. WITH CAL FIRE. I
WOULD THINK THAT WHAT THIS.
THIS TO GO TO SAY IN TERMS OF
HOW WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT. THE
FUTURE. IS ENSURING THAT OUR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS. ARE PART
OF THE- SOLUTION IN TERMS OF
ACTIVELY BEING ABLE TO RESPOND
TO THESE FIRES. DURING THE TIME
PERIOD WE WERE OFFICIALLY NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE ON OUR FARM.
WHICH WAS OUTSIDE OF THE
DECORATIONS ON THIS IS THE CASE
FOR. EVERYBODY ELSE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AS WELL- OF WHICH
PROBABLY MORE THAN HALF. OF THE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
STAYING. BEHIND BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THEY HAD TO BE THE
ONES TO FIGHT THE FIRE
THEMSELVES. TO A LARGE DEGREE.
IT MAKING SITUATION A BIT MORE
DANGEROUS BECAUSE WHEN WE
NEEDED TO GO FOR EXAMPLE PICK
UP SUPPLIES- WE COULDN'T GET-
WE CAN GET THOSE BECAUSE WE CAN
GO THROUGH A BOX. ONE OF MY
NEIGHBORS FOR EXAMPLE. OUR
NEIGHBORING FARM- HE WAS
ACTIVELY FIGHTING THE FIRE-
THAT WAS THE SPOT FOR A FEW
DAYS AFTERWARDS. FROM CATCHING.
IT STARTING A FIRE ON HIS BAR-
WE ENDED UP- HEATED UP. HAVING
A PIPE BURST. AND HE USUALLY
WOULD CALL THE LOCAL. THE
COMPANY AND HAVE THEM- DELIVER
A- THANK YOU. THEY COULD DO
THAT BECAUSE THERE ARE. AND SO
HE ENDED UP BACK HAVING TO DOWN
TO THE BLOCK. AND IT WAS
ACTUALLY NOT PERMITTED EVEN
HAVE THEM PAST THE HYPE OVER
THE ROAD BLOCK. TO AN- ARM IT
SHOULD THEY HAVING HAVING A LOT
MORE DANGEROUS SITUATION TERMS
OF HIS ABILITY TO DEFEND THE
HIGHER. I THINK THAT. IN THE
FUTURE HAS AS SOME OF THE
OTHER. SPEAKERS HAVE MENTIONED.
WE NEED TO BE A BIT MORE- PART
OF THE SOLUTION IN TERMS OF
RECOGNIZING THAT WE AS FARMERS
AND RANCHERS HAVE A LOT OF THE
TOOLS EQUIPMENT KNOWLEDGE
SKILLS. TO ADDRESS THESE FIRES
AS THEIR CURRENT BEFORE THEY'RE
OCCURRING- AND ALSO IN THE
PROGRAMME PREPARATION PROCESS-
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO-
THINK ABOUT THINGS LIKE- LIKE
YOU KNOW. ESSENTIALLY CREATING
CRANK HARBERTS RUN AROUND
AROUND AREAS WHICH IS.
SOMETHING THAT THAT COLD BE
LEGISLATED- AND HAVING THE
FUNDS TO DO THAT. IN ADDITION
TO THAT BEING ABLE TO- BEING
ABLE TO ALSO FOCUS ON COVER
CROPPING AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE-
LAND THAT RETAIN MORE MOISTURE
SO DEALS FOR EXAMPLE COULD BE
COVER CROPS WHICH- HAS A NUMBER
OF OTHER POSITIVE IMPACTS
BEYOND. YOU KNOW FIVE ATTENTION
TERMS OF BILLING SOIL CAPTURING
CARBON. AND SO ON- IN ADDITION
TO THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE EXPERIENCED THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL- LEGISLATIVELY- AS-
NUMBER FOCUS SPOKEN ON FIRE
INSURANCE I DON'T WANT TO BE
GOT TO MUCH BECAUSE OUR FOLKS
HAVE BUT THAT'S ALSO A VERY
CRITICAL THING. FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO-
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE LAST
YOU KNOW. HOW DOZEN YEARS OR SO
OF WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE- AND
BEYOND THAT IS- THINKING MORE
ABOUT HOW- WE CAN WE CAN USE
THIS MOMENT TO. INCLUDE FARMERS
RANCHERS IN AND RESTORING A LOT
OF LANDS. THAT HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED- THERE. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A NUMBER OF VERY
SERIOUS RUSSIAN ISSUES IN OUR
AREA AND THERE HASN'T BEEN.
MUCH EFFORT. THUS FAR TO
ADDRESS THAT- I WOULD HOPE THAT
THAT WE CAN USE- FARMERS AND
RANCHERS SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
IN TERMS OF. AN EQUIPMENT IN
ADDITION THAT TO BE ABLE TO
FOCUS ON RESTORATION. OF A LOT
OF LANDS AROUND OUR FARMS- I
THINK. THE MORE OF THE STORY IN
MY OPINION IS THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES
FARMERS RANCHERS. IN THE FIRE
PREPARATION. ACTIVE RESPONSE.
AND RESTORATION PROCESS. AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN. HAVE IT. IN A
CERTAIN DEGREE OF CRAZINESS IN
TERMS OF ORGANIZING HOW THE
SYSTEMS COULD LOOK. BUT I IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES. LIKE OURS
IT'S ESSENTIAL BECAUSE- AS AS
WE SAW ON THE PARTICULAR.
THEY'RE JUST WEST ENOUGH
REACHED- DIVIDE THE FACT OF THE
AREA IT JUST REALISTICALLY. IT
WASN'T A CASE IN AND IT IS NOT
TO. BLAME ANYBODY BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED CAL FIRED AN
INCREDIBLE JOB FOR THAT THE
FOLKS WHO WERE HERE- THE
FIREFIGHTERS WERE WERE.
ACTUALLY AEROBIC. BUT I DO
THINK THOUGH THAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN INCLUDE
OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FACING THESE
FIRES- I GREATLY APPRECIATE YOU
GUYS HAVING ME HERE TODAY. AND
I HOPE THAT THAT- WE CAN WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD IN TERMS OF
CREATING. MORE COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTIONS- IN IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING FIRES AND BEING
PREPARED FOR THE FUTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND COLD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING THE TIME-
AND PJ YOUR TESTIMONY- VERY
INFORMATIVE. OUR FINAL SPEAKER
FOR THIS PANEL WILL BE JOINING
US FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM- ARNOLFO
SOLORIO WITH THE NAP UP
FARMWORKERS FOUNDATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU WE DON'T SEE YOU
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO BE OUT OF
THAT THERE YOU ARE FANTASTIC'S
ANALOGOUS TO YOU AND HERE YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THE WHOLE COMMITTEE. R. MY NAME
IS UNOFFICIAL AUDIO- I'M HERE
REPRESENTING- NAPA VALLEY
FARMWORKER FOUNDATION ABOUT
WILDFIRE IMPACT ON UP OF ALL
THE FARMWORKERS. THE MISSION OF
ENOUGH FOR FARMWORKERS
FOUNDATION IS TO SUPPORT AND
PROMOTE NAPA VALLEY'S VINEYARD
WORKERS THROUGH EDUCATION AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. THE
NAPA VALLEY FARMWORKER
FOUNDATION IS THE FIRST OF THE
SKYLINE IN THE UNITED STATES.
IN NOW OTHER REGIONS HAVE BEGUN
MODELLING COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AFTER IT. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE HAVE A
REACH OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
BEING YOUR WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND PROVIDED ALMOST
THREE THOUSAND HOURS. OF
EDUCATION. WHILE A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES LACK PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND RESOURCES FOR
FARMWORKERS. WE HAVE FOCUSED ON
CREATING ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING. INCREASING
FARMWORKERS TECHNICOLOR SKILL
SETS IN OPPORTUNITIES ARE FOR
UPWARD MOBILITY. IN A TYPICAL
YEAR OUR BROAD RANGE OF FREE
CLASSES FOR NAPA COUNTY
FARMWORKERS INCLUDES ENGLISH
LEADERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT
TRAINING. MEDICAL TRAINING MY-
NOT BE GETTING THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM. A SCHOOL SYSTEM. ELEGY
TRAINING AND MORE. EMERGENCY
STATE OF THE NAPA COUNTY ONE
GRAPE INDUSTRY. TODAY WE ARE IN
A STATE OF EMERGENCY. SMOKE
FROM BOTH THE L. ANNUAL
LIGHTING COMPLEX FIRE IN GLASS
FIRE HOUSE BECAUSE GROWERS AND
WINERIES HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS DUE TO DAMAGE CROPS
AND CANCEL GREAT PURCHASE
CONTRACTS. THE CLASSIFIED ALONE
HAS BEEN ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN
UP TO ONE BILLION IN LOSSES TO
THE WINE INDUSTRY. FOR THOSE
WITH CROP INSURANCE COVERAGE
RARELY EQUALS FULL MARKET PRICE.
IN THERE CURRENTLY IS NO
DISASTER RELIEF AVAILABLE FOR
LOSSES RESULTING FROM SMOKE
DAMAGE. ALL OF THESE HAS A BIG
IMPACT ON FARMWORKERS. OUR
PREMIUM FREE MILITARY ANALYSIS
SHOWS THAT HAVE BEEN YOUR
WORKER HAVE LOST AN AVERAGE OF
FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EACH
WHICH COULD EQUATE TO NEARLY
FIFTY MILLION IN LOST WAGES.
SOME WINERIES REPORT THAT NOT
TWENTY TWENTY VINTAGE WOULD BE
PRODUCE. WHICH POINTS TO A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF GRAVES
GOING ON HARVEST IN MANY HOURS
OF WORK LAST. FARMWORKER
FOUNDATION FIRE RESPONSE AND
HOW LEGISLATORS CAN SUPPORTER
FARMWORKERS NOW. THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA WORKER FOUNDATION IS
ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT THE WHOLE PERSON
THIS MEANS SUPPORTING
FARMWORKERS AND NOT ONLY AS
WORKERS BUT AS A COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTING THEIR
FAMILIES. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PLAY A ROLE IN HELPING KEEP
FARMWORKERS SAFE THE RECENT
DISASTERS. BY PROVIDING SAFETY
IN WILDFIRE RISK OF THE PATIENT
AND DISTRIBUTING ESSENTIAL B.
B. E. PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. INCLUDING TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND NINETY FIVE
MOSQUES LEVINE YOUR CRUISE.
HOWEVER IT IS MORE THAT CAN BE
DONE TO SUPPORT FOR WORKING
FAMILIES. WE BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATOR CAN HELP WITH THIS.
SOME EXAMPLES HERE BUT NOT
FINANCIAL AND SOCIAL SAFETY NET
SUPPORT. CURRENTLY THE
FARMWORKER FOUNDATION IS
WORKING THROUGH THE NAPA VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION WILD
WILDFIRE RELIEF PROGRAM DO SO
FOR FARMWORKERS WHO LEAVE IN
NAPA COUNTY WITH AN EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR RENT.
WORKERS LEAVE IT IN NAPA COUNTY
ABLE TO APPLY FOR FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN EMERGENCY
RIGHT NOW SO EIGHT THIS IS A
HUGE HELP. BUT WE KNOW THAT IT
IS STILL FALLS SHORT OF WHAT IS
NEEDED. WILSON ALL THEY ARE
FARMWORKERS WORKING UP A
COUNTY. FOR SOCIAL ECONOMIC
REASONS DON'T LEAVE THEIR AND
THEY ALSO NEED OUR SUPPORT. WE
ASK LEGISLATORS TO CONSIDER
WAYS TO PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING.
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR WORKING FAMILIES FOR
HOUSING RENTAL ASSISTANCE FOR
GROCERIES FOR CHILDCARE WHILE
FARMWORKERS CONTINUE TO BE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS DURING COMIC
NINETEEN. THE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES TO OUR FIRE SAFETY
PREPAREDNESS AND EDUCATION. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO NEED ACCESS TO
PROPER PP EVACUATION CENTERS
AND TEMPORARY HOUSING. WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE DIGITAL THE BY
THE BY THAT EXCLUDES
FARMWORKERS FROM TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMMUNICATION. IT TO DISTRIBUTE
MORE INFORMATION FROM
TRUSTWORTHY SOURCES AND THE
SPANISH. WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE INDIVIDUALS AND
EMPLOYERS AND HOW TO PROTECT
THEIR THEIR HEALTH DURING
WILDFIRE. WE BELIEVE IN
REPETITIVE AND CONSISTENT
OUTREACH AND HAVE PROVIDED
MATERIALS WEBINARS AND TRAINING.
MORE FUNDING AND RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING. MR SOLORIO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
AFTERNOON I KNOW THAT WE HAD A
LOT OF SPEAKERS ON A PANEL DO
WE HAVE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR- ANY PERSON WHO OP.
PROVIDED SOME TESTIMONY. MATHIS.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHICH ONE
OF OUR PANELISTS COULD ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF THE LACK OF
INSURANCE PROTECTION THE BEST
BUT I BY- MAYBE FARM BUREAU OR
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN. DIGGING A LITTLE
DEEPER. INTO THE IMPACTS OF
HAVING THOSE INSURANCES CUT
FROM OUR AG. SECTOR IF INVADE
LIKE TO ELABORATE ON THAT I
THINK- HEARING MORE WOULD BE
GOOD. DONALD TRUMP WANTS. THE
FIRST QUESTION- YOU KNOW  MEAN
IT REALLY IS IT'S IN TERMS OF
GETTING CAPITAL BEING ABLE TO
RAISE CAPITAL EITHER DAY TO
GROW YOUR FARM OR O GET TO THE
NEXT HARVEST SEASON IN TERMS OF
GETTING LOANS- YOU KNOW SO IT
IS NOT A NEW PROBLEM IS GONNA
BE EXASPERATED EVEN MORE I KNOW
I BLAST NUMBERS I SAW. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS
I BELIEVE FOLLOWING LAST
WILDFIRE SEASON TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THEY'RE ESTIMATING
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST FARMS AND RANCHES- WOULD
BE- WOULD NOT BE RENEWED IT
WOULD HAVE TO TURN TO THE FAIR
PLAN- IT'S SO YOU HAVE TO THINK
AFTER BURNING FOUR MILLION
ACRES. WHAT THOSE NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE I'VE ASKED IF YOU
WOULD HAVE ASKED THE INSURANCE.
INDUSTRY IF THERE IS OVERALL
NUMBERS. BIGGEST CONCERNS WE
HAVE IN OUR INSURANCE AGENTS
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
PULLING COMPLETELY OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. WHICH ONLY LEAVES A
FEW VENDORS LEFT WHO WOULD EVEN
BE WILLING MAYBE TO TAKE A RISK
THERE BUT THAT'S NEVER GOOD FOR
CONSUMERS- WHAT THAT. LITTLE
COMPETITION- ED BUT THE BIGGEST
IMPACT WE HAVE INSURANCE NOW IS
HAPPENING IS THAT THESE FIRES
THIS YEAR WE'RE STILL
CATASTROPHIC AND BURNED SO. HOT
AND FAST. IT BURNED. FARMLAND
THAT NORMALLY YOU WOULDN'T SEE
IN A WILD FIRE ZONE EVEN IN THE
EVEN A STANISLAUS AND SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTIES WE WERE SEEING
FIRES AND EVACUATIONS-
HAPPENING. OR UNHEARD OF AND SO
YOU SAW. YOU KNOW THE- THE
DIFFERENT COMMODITIES THAT WERE
AFFECTED BY THIS AND OF COURSE.
YOU KNOW- WHAT WAS REALLY
SHOCKING TO US AS WE GOT THE
FIRST LETTERS- A FROM OUR
MEMBERS. FROM THE FAIR PLAN-
DENYING THEM. AN INSURANCE
POLICY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T-
INSURE FARMS AND RANCHES. I
THINK THAT WAS THE MOST
SHOCKING DISCOVERY AND THE MOST
DISTURBING- THAT LEAVES US
HANGING. BUT CERTAINLY SOME
THAT WE NEED TO DIVE IN. INTO
DEEPER AND HOW WE GET AROUND
THAT WE NEED TO DO IT FAST SO
THEY THEY WERE DENIED THE FAIR
PLAN. YEAH DATE OF THE FAIR
PLAN DOES NOT INSURE FARMS AND
RANCHES- THEY THEY WON'T
INSURE- LIKE BARNES AND ALL OF
THAT. ALL RIGHT THAT'S CLEARLY
SOMETHING WE NEED TO LOOK AT
AND THEN ALSO- WHAT WELL I HAVE
YOU THERE- I KNOW THE- THERE'S
A COMMENTS- BY DOCTORED DALY
YEAH- BUT- THE WIRE HERE IN AND
IF YOU STILL HERE IF YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS IT AS WELL BUT ABOUT
CERTIFICATION- FORGETTING IN TO
REMOVE LIVESTOCK- FROM AG LANDS
I KNOW- FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT
DEAL. DO WITH THAT GREATLY-%
MISTER LACEY- THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA CALLUM
IN MY DISTRICT- AND SEVERAL
OTHERS BUT- I KNOW IT'S ALWAYS
A STRUGGLE TO GET UP TO GET
PAST- WHERE ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIRE BLOCKED THE ROADS- BUT BUT
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON-
SERCHHIP. CERTIFIATION PROCESS
AND I KNOW THERE'S AN EXISTING
ONE BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
HURDLES- I'D I'D LOVE TO HEAR
FROM ANYONE ON THE PANEL THAT%
LIKE TO SPEAK TO WHAT THAT'LL
LOOK LIKE. YEAH- IF IT'S
SOMETHING- YOU'LL THINK
ADMINISTRATIVELY WE CAN ADJUST
FIRE HONOR IF IT'S- A
LEGISLATIVE THING- WE NEED TO
LOOK AT AS FAR AS MAYBE A
POSSIBLE. FUTURE COMMITTEE BILL
FROM US- LOVE TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS YEAH. YEAH AND WE WANT
TO BE SAYS EVERYTHING THERE'S A
LOT OF POSSIBILITY OF THEIR THE
HURDLES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
EXISTING FOR- VENDORS WHO
CONTRIBUTE TO FIGHTING- FIRES.
IT'S REALLY- IT'S A CLASS THAT
THEY TAKE A ONE DAY EIGHT HOUR
CLASS TO BE CERTIFIED SAY THE
DRIVE A WATER TRUCK OR TO
OPERATE A CHAINSAW. WE THINK
THERE COULD BE ROOM IN THERE
AND WE ARE SENSITIVE TO THE
FACT AND AS ONE OF THE
PANELISTS STATED I MYSELF IN
THIS LAST EVACUATION DIDN'T
LEAVE MY FAMILY DID- I STAYED
ON THE FARM TO KEEP THE
GENERATOR'S GOING TO KEEP THE
ANIMALS FED KNOWING ONCE YOU
LEAVE YOU CAN'T GET BACK IN.
BUT WE KNOW OUR COMMUNITY WE
KNOW OUR SHERIFF'S YOU KNOW THE
DEPUTIES WE KNOW OUR-
KALIFORNIA MEMBERS THERE SO
THEY KNOW WHERE WE'RE AT BUT WE
WANT TO BE SENSITIVE THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
RUSHING IN THE TIME WHICH PUTS
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS IN A IN A
BAD SITUATION SPENDING MORE
TIME. CALLING US SO IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE I KNOW DOCTOR
DALY. AND CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA FARM YOU
HAVE HAD A LOT OF SKETCH AND
YOU ALSO HAVE ANOTHER PANELIST
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GONNA TALK-ON IT BUT SOMEONE TO PURSUE AS
WELL MISTER- DAN MAKING IS
COMING UP I KNOW HE HAS HAD
SOME- SOME CONVERSATIONS- WITH
ALL OF US ABOUT WHAT THAT WOULD
LOOK LIKE SO WE'RE IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS BUT WE DO WANT
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
SENSITIVITY. AND DON'T WANT TO
JEOPARDIZE WHAT THE FIRST ROLL
OF KALIFORNIA IS AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT MANY
TIMES. WE APPRECIATE THE BRING-
FIRST RESPONDERS FROM OUTSIDE
THE AREA WHO MAYBE. DON'T KNOW
US AS WELL AS WE KNOW THE LOCAL
FIRST RESPONDERS SO.
COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT CERTAINLY
DOCTOR DAILY RECORD IF YOU WANT
TO SAY SOMETHING ELSE OR- THE
CERTAINLY- DISTRACT YOU KNOW
AT. THAT THAT THE CHAIRS
LEISURE OF COURSE BUT I'D I'D
LOVE TO HEAR MORE. VERY QUICKLY
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ONE ACCESS IS
CRITICAL. I DO EMPHASIZE- WHAT.
MR HANSEN SAID THOUGH IN THAT
IS THAT. WE AREN'T SUGGESTING
ANYONE WHO HAS TO GO TO THE DOG
GETS IN ANYTIME THEY WANT I
THINK THAT PUTS PEOPLE IN AN
AWKWARD SITUATION. WE DON'T
WANNA DO THAT THE FIRST
RESPONDERS. BUT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN AND I KNOW THE FARMER
WAS DONE SO AS WELL. TO LOOK AT
SOME SOLUTIONS WHERE WE CAN GET
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING. FOR
CERTIFIED PEOPLE WHO COULD HAVE
ACCESS AT APPROPRIATE TIMES. I
AND I THINK WE'RE GETTING CLOSE
IN OUR PARTICULAR COUNTY WE MET
WITH OUR AG COMMISSIONER'S SEAT
THERE'S A- ROAD MAP THERE. THAT
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL IF WE CAN
GET THAT CERTIFICATION BUT
AGAIN WITHOUT. COOPERATION FROM
ALL AGENCIES. CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS C. H. P. AS WELL AS THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. IT MIGHT FALL
ON MOODY YEARS I'VE BEEN TURNED
BACK BEFORE. AT AT ROAD BLOCKS.
AND HAD TO GO CROSS COUNTRY
WHICH IS ACTUALLY MORE
DANGEROUS JUST TO BE ABLE TO
GET WATER AND FEED THE
LIVESTOCK SO. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
PURSUING IT THANK YOU. IF I MAY
SPEAK ON ON ON THE SAME
QUESTION FOR JUST A MOMENT AS
WELL CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME OKAY.
SURE IF YOU CAN- BRIEFLY MAKE
OR KEEP. YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF
WOULD BE GREAT. OF COURSE YES-
BUSINESSES CALL MY SERVICE I
THOUGHT YOU- I JUST WANT TO
SPEAK HONEST RETAILERS
REGARDING LIVESTOCK IN
PARTICULAR PERSPECTIVE UP
SMALLER FARMS. THIS BECAME A
BIG ISSUE FOR ONE OF OUR
NEIGHBORS- WHO WHO IS A VERY
SMALL FARM BUT HAS A WIDE A
WIDE NUMBER OF- A RABBIT. DUCKS
AND CHICKENS- IF FOR HIM AS A
SMALL PERSON DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE EQUIPMENT TO
MOVE LARGE AMOUNTS OF LIVESTOCK
AT ONCE. BEING ABLE TO GET IN
AND OUT OF THE FIRESTONE- BUT
TRANSFER ALL THE LIVESTOCK OUT
IS NOT NECESSARILY REALISTIC.
HE HAS FONG WAS NOT REALLY WITH
IN HARM'S WAY OF THE FIRE
DIRECTLY IT WAS AWAY FROM IT-
AND HE FELT IT WAS NECESSARY TO
STAY THERE TO KEEP ANIMALS
ALIVE OTHERWISE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THEY WOULD HAVE.
JUST DIED BECAUSE THE
REGULATIONS ON WAS IN PLACE FOR
OVER TEN DAYS- I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BE A BIT MORE CREATIVE
IN TERMS OF PINPOINTING WHAT
AREAS ARE ALSO TRULY IN DANGER
VERSES WHICH ARE ARE ARE NOT
ANARCHIST KIND OF WITHIN THE
GREATER. DON'T MATCH THAT'S
EASY TO MAINTAIN DUE TO
ROADBLOCKS- BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU YOU NEED TO CREATE A
CERTAIN DEGREE OF MISTRUST
AMONG- FOLKS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR HAVE
FARMERS IT IS SMALL FARMERS WHO
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO. GET
THEIR ANIMALS IN AND OUT AND
JUST ARE GOING TO STAY PERIOD.
BECAUSE THEY THEY KNOW
OTHERWISE THEIR ARMS WILL DIE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FANTASTIC
THANKS I JUST WANTED TO ADD
WE'VE HAD- THE A PROCESS
INVOLVING IN CINEMA COUNTY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FARM
BUREAU ARE AG COMMISSIONER THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND CAL FIRE
VOLUNTEERS- SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND HOW WE FOUND IT
MOST SUCCESSFULLY WORKING- AND
THIS PAST AUGUST WE ACTUALLY
DID FIRE SAFETY TRAINING A CAL
FIRE VOLUNTEER AND OUR DEPUTY
SHERIFF CAME IN WE HAD FARMERS-
RANCHERS WINEGROWERS TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY AT A TIME GOING
THROUGH A FIVE HOUR
CERTIFICATION CLASS. IN TERMS
OF UNDERSTANDING HOW FIRE MOVES
IN AND OUT THINGS TO BE CAREFUL
FOR LOOK FOR SO WE COULD DID A
CERTIFICATION THAT WAY AND WE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO PROCESS WITH
THE AYE COMMISSION THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE WHERE THE AG
COMMISSIONER- VALIDATES A
LEGITIMATE COMMERCIAL
OPERATIONS AND WHAT WOULD BE
DEEMED EMERGENCY FARM
ACTIVITIES LIKE TAKING FEEDING
CATTLE MILKING COWS HARVESTING
ETCETERA AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT VALIDATION TO THE
FARMERS OFTHAT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE A COMMERCIAL OPERATION IN
A VIRGINIA MEMBERS OF THE
ACTIVITY. THEY THEN TAKE THAT
PASSED- CERTIFICATE OF
VALIDATION AND AT THE POINT OF
ENTRY IS WHEN THE SHERIFF
DETERMINES WHAT IF AND WHEN
IT'S SAFE TO GO TO THAT
SPECIFIC ADDRESS THAT'S ON THAT
PASSED SO THAT WAY WE SORT OF
WE'VE DONE THE TRAINING IN
ADVANCE WE'VE DONE THE
VALIDATION THAT'S NOT YOU KNOW
DAHLE GONNA GO IT'S AN ACTUAL
COMMERCIAL THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
FARM ACTIVIA HAS TO HAPPEN AND
THEN WE MAKE THE FINAL SAFETY
CALL AT THAT POINT IN TIME OF
ENTRY AND SO. WE'VE SEEN THAT
BE FAIRLY SUCCESSFUL I'M
WORKING THROUGH AND WE ACTUALLY
ARE STARTING TO WORK WITH OTHER
REGIONS AND- OTHER AYE
COMMISSIONERS BARBARO'S AND-
OTHER WINEGROWING ASSOCIATIONS
TO SEE HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
TO MAKE THAT BETTER. AND EVEN
OFFER MORE BROADLY THAT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISS CRUZ- I THINK.
IN IN BACK TO MY OWN DISTRICT
WE SAW THIS- ED SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PHONE CALLS OF THE
FOLKS THAT WERE AFRAID TO COME
DOWN OFF THE MOUNTAIN- THEY'RE
LIKE YEAH I KNOW I KNOW I CAN
GO TO. THE THE FAIRGROUNDS TWO
TWO THE CENTER AND IN APPLYING
GET A PERMIT AND EVERYTHING
ELSE BUT THEN IF I CAN'T GET IT
TODAY OR OR THE LINES BACKED UP
FOR WHATEVER THEN YOU KNOW
THEY'RE REALLY GONNA FAMILY
MEMBER SOMEBODY ELSE UP ON THE
MOUNTAIN CELLS WITHOUT
TRANSPORTATION. ECCENTRICITY
THINK HAVING SOME KIND OF A
PERMIT SYSTEM THE CERTIFICATE-
I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
YOU KNOW IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR ACT COMMISSIONERS AND OUR
SHARES AND OUR FIRE TO MAKE
SURE THE EDUCATIONS OF THEIR-
OBVIOUSLY THEY DO HAVE TO
TRACK- WHERE THEY'RE GOING AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS BUT ON A I
THINK HAVING SOMETHING THAT.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS HEY THIS
IS WHAT IT IS- MAKES SENSE
ESPECIALLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE ALWAYS SEE SOMETHING
HAPPEN AND ONE LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND THEN ANOTHER
AND THEN OTHER PEOPLE ARE
WONDERING WHAT'S GOING ON-
WE'VE SEEN THIS BE A CLEAR
PROBLEM. SO I'D LOVE TO. SEE
SOME KIND OF A WHITE PAPER FROM
FROM THE AG- FOLKS OUT THERE ON
WHAT THIS OUGHT TO LOOK LIKE-
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH- CALIFORNIE
IN THE AG COMMISSIONERS TO ON
SOMETHING WE ALL COULD AGREE
ON. MAYBE YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
COULD RUN THAT AS A- COMMITTEE.
BILL OR SOMETHING TO JUST GET
SOMETHING OUT THERE THAT WAY
EVERYBODY KNOWS. HEY HERE'S THE
PROCESS I'M GONNA GO DOWN AND-
THIS IS THE CLASS AND THESE ARE
TIMES WHEN TO TAKE IT AND- NOW
I KNOW SO NEXT SEASON WE'RE-
ALL SET AND READY TO GO AND NOT
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT- MR
LEVINE. IT IS. LIKE IT'S A FAIR.
HE THANK YOU MR HANSEN RAISED
THE ISSUE ABOUT AND NINETY FIVE
MASKS AND YOU KNOW AT THE
BEGINNING F THE YEAR IF I WAS
TOLD I WAS GONNA BE PUTTING ON
A FACE MASK AS MUCH AS I'D BE
PUTTING ON SOCKS I'D BE IN
DISBELIEF- THE N. NINETY FIVE
MASKS ARE TECHNICALLY SPECIFIC
AND THERE IS A FEAR. THAT YOU
KNOW THEY JUST WON'T BE ENOUGH
TO GO AROUND AND I DON'T THINK
WE WERE BEING PUSHED TO WEAR
FACE MASKS IN THE BEGINNING- SO
MUCH AS TO PRESERVE WHAT PP WAS
THERE FOR FIRST RESPONDERS FOR
HOSPITALS AND- AND SO THERE WAS
A CONCERN. THAT THE FIRST-AVAILABILITY ACCESSIBILITY TO
BUY THAT AT THE SCALE THAT
AGRICULTURE NEEDED THAT IT JUST
WASN'T GOING TO BE POSSIBLE-
AND YET THERE WAS- THERE IS
CONCERN THAT. YOU KNOW IF WE
WEREN'T GOING TO BE GETTING THE
N. NINETY FIVE MASKS THAT WE
NEED FOR AGRICULTURE THAT THAT
WAS GOING TO BE- REALLY
DISADVANTAGEOUS FOR THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO FOR THOSE WHO ARE WORKING
IN AGRICULTURE- HOW REAL- WHERE
THOSE CONCERNS AND HOW WE SEEN
THEM COME EVEN OUT AS SUPPLY-
YOU KNOW BECAME HEALTHIER- AND
THE- YOU KNOW LOGISTICS OF
GETTING WHAT WE NEEDED- BECAME
MORE CLEAR- JUST LIKE. YOU KNOW
TWELVE PAPERS BACK ON SHELVES-
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION. AND OF
PANDEMIC IN THIS LET'S DANCE TO
BECAUSE WE KNEW WE COME INTO
WILDFIRE SEASON ENDED WITH THE
NEW SMOKE THAT REGULATIONS ARE
COMES TO OUR OUR WORK FORCE ARE
PLEASE. THE NEED FOR THOSE
MASS. BUT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC E ARE ASKED TO GIVE
UP OUR STOCKPILE THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND IF YOU REMEMBER
EVEN THE CDC WAS SAYING IF YOU
ARE NOT A FIRST RESPONDER. AND
DON'T WEAR A MASK THAT WAS
LATER CHANGED- SO WE GAVE OUR
SUPPLY THAT WE HAD AN
AGRICULTURE ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION MASS TO THE FIRST
RESPONDERS BUT KEPT REMINDING
EVERYBODY. THAT IS ONLY A
NINETY FIVE MASS THAT IS WHAT
YOU KNOW THAT CAL OSHA
CERTIFIES- TO- TO GET OUR WORK
FORCE. IN CASE OF- THAT SMOKE
WORK DAYS- BUT THERE'S ALSO THE
CAYENNE NINETY FIVE OUT THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TIME TRYING TO
GET THAT CERTIFIED AS WELL
COULD THAT MEET THE
CERTIFICATION SO. NOR THAT
PROCESS IS WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
USE THE K. AND NINETY FIVE BUT
THAT IS CERTAINLY AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT COULD BE OUT
THERE IN AN EMERGENCY SITUATION
LIKE THIS AND THE OTHER. PART
THAT REALLY WAS HOW EARLY YOU
KNOW THE FIRE I HAVE BACKED
AWAY FROM ON SEPTEMBER NINTH I
BELIEVE. THAT EIGHT ACTUALLY
STARTED ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH OR
AUGUST SIXTEENTH IN PLUMAS
COUNTY. AND HOW LONG THOSE DAYS
WERE AND HOW EARLY IT STARTED-
REALLY PUT US A BEHIND IN TERMS
OF HAVING THAT THE THOSE FACE
MASK FOR A WORKERS. COMP BUT WE
ARE WE ARE WE ARE RIGHT WHERE
WE WERE IN MARCH IN TERMS OF
AVAILABILITY. AND THE SHORTAGES
WITH THE MASS. ALL RIGHT AND
YOU YOU MAY HAVE BEEN ASKING
THE QUESTION EARLIER ON ABOUT
OR RAISING THE ISSUE ABOUT
TREES THAT WERE BEING CUT DOWN.
YES YEAH IT SO YOU WOULDN'T
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE- THE
FIRE HAZARD MITIGATION THAT
UTILITIES ARE DOING THE TREES
ARE YOU'RE TALKING TO OR
ACTUALLY IN ORCHARD IS OUR
NETWORK THAT ARE ACTIVELY
FARMED THEY HAVE EASEMENTS OF
THE POWER LINES TO THE ORCHARDS
STARPOINT REALLY IS THAT THAT
IS NOT WHERE THE FOCUS SHOULD
BE NOT SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
ORCHARDS RIGHT NOW IN TERMS THE
TIMELINESS OF HAVING TO CUT
THESE TREES AND MITIGATE OR
THE FIRE RISK- THAT THE
UTILITIES SHOULD REALLY SPEND
THE TIME. IN THOSE HIGH SEVERE
WILDFIRE AREAS AND NOT IN OUR
ORCHARDS AND LITERALLY FARMERS
WAKE UP WITH EQUIPMENT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ORCHARDS AND THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE THERE- WITH
THEIR TREES GETTING STOPPED AND
WOOD. DO YOU HAVE. WITH THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE RAISING
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
APPROPRIATE. HAVE YOU MAPPED OR
OR CONSIDERED WE'RE THE HIGHER
RISK LINES ARE SO FOR EXAMPLE
P. GENIES OWN INSPECTIONS- ON.
THE THE LINE YOU KNOW THAT
STARTED- THAT THEY CAN'T FIRE
FOR EXAMPLE I WAS VERY WELL
KNOWN- THAT THEY NEED TO DO
THAT WORK IN IT THEY DIDN'T DO
THAT WORK. SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING
IN AND BIãU I THINK YOU'D
MENTIONED YOU SPECIFICALLY ARE
YOU LOOKING OUTLINES THAT HAVE
PASSED TESTS AND HAVE. GONE
THROUGH MORE RIGOROUS
INSPECTIONS AND HAVE HAD BEEN
UPDATED MORE RECENTLY THAN THE
HUNDRED YEAR OLD LINES THAT
PG&E DID NOT DO THE WORK ON OR
ARE YOU JUST SAYING WE JUST
DON'T WANT THIS BEING DONE
NEAR- THE FARMED ORCHARDS. WELL
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW FOR POWER
TRANSMISSION ITSELF IT IT YOU
DON'T WE KNOW OUR WHICH HAS TO
BE LOOKED AT BUT WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE WHERE WE'RE AT NOT
JUST MEETING A GOAL OF REMOVING
SO MUCH- SO MUCH FUEL TO MEET
OUR REQUIREMENTS- YOU KNOW FROM
CAL FIRE STATE BILL. BUT THAT
IS THAT IT SHOULD ONLY BE THE
PARTY SHOULD BE WHERE THOSE
ACTUAL FIRE RISKS ARE AND I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE
MAPS YOU KNOW YOU THAT IF THE
TERMS WHAT PG&E IS LOOKING AT
WHETHER. HIGH RISK ARE I WILL
TELL YOU THE MAPS ARE OUT THERE
WHERE THERE IS A HIGH RISK OF
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA. AT THE
START OF THIS YEAR WAS THAT IF
IDENTIFIED EXTREMELY HIGH RISK
FOR WILDFIRES IS TEN MILLION
ACRES. SO WE CAN SIT HERE AND
TALK ABOUT HOW WE BURKE FOUR
MILLION ACRES BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER SIX MILLION STILL OUT
THERE THEY'RE CONSIDERED
EXTREME HIGH RISK BUT WHAT WE
SAW BURNING IN THIS FIRE.
WASN'T JUST THE EXTREME HIGH
RISK. SO BAG THAT. OUR OUR
POSITION IS LIKE LET'S
PRIORITIZE WHAT LIMITED FUNDS
WE DO GET EVERY YEAR OR WHAT
TIME WINDOW WE HAVE. LET'S
PRIORITIZE AND MAKE SURE TRULY
IS IN A HIGH RISK FIRE AREA
WHERE WE ARE. DEALING WITH
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. I THINK
MISTER. THANK YOU. HI
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AN
INTEREST TIME SINCE WE'RE
ALMOST OUT OF TIME SEVEN OF THE
PANEL WILL HAVE TO MOVE ON. I
APPRECIATE- THE PANELISTS. THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THAT PREVIOUS
PANEL- THIS THIRD PANEL
AGRICULTURE BASED WILDFIRE
MITIGATION- THAT'S THE FOCUS.
LIKE TO INVITE OUR OUR NEXT
PANELIST FOR- THIS ISSUE WHICH
IS- DAN MOREN. COUNTY DIRECTOR
UC COOPERATIVE EXTENSION OF
PLASTER NEVADA- HE I BELIEVE IS
HERE. AN REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE AND FOR
TAKING ON THIS REALLY CRITICAL
TOPIC. MY NAME IS DAN MAKIN I
AM THE LIVESTOCK AND NATURAL
RESOURCES ADVISER WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND I'VE
BEEN CALLED MUCH WORSE OR IT'S
OKAY. NO WORRIES NO WORRIES. I
AM ALSO THE COUNTY DIRECTOR FOR
PLASTER IN NEVADA COUNTY AND-
LIKE A LOT OF BALL GUYS I WEAR
MANY DIFFERENT HATS AND I'M
ALSO A SMALL SCALE SHEEP
PRODUCER IN PLASTER COUNTY JUST
UP THE HILL HERE- I SHOULD
START BY SAYING THAT MY
COMMENTS TODAY ARE BASED ON MY
RESEARCH AND MY- EXPERIENCE AND
DON'T NECESSARILY REPRESENT THE
VIEWPOINT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- BUT THAT BEING
SAID. YOU SEE AG AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND COOPER EXTENSION.
HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS RESOURCE
THROUGHOUT. THIS CRISIS ON THE
GROUND AND IN AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- I THINK. IT AND
REFLECTING ON WHAT PREVIOUS
PANELISTS HAVE SAID THAT THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AGRICULTURE IS
A PART OF THE SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE- NOT ONLY ADDRESSING
BEFORE THE FIRE HAPPENS AND
BEING ABLE TO HELP ADDRESS
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRE BUT BUT
THEN IN THE RECOVERY PROCESS AS
WELL. AND I'D LIKE TO TOUCH ON
JUST ONE AREA WHERE I THINK
THERE'S SOME REAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR AGRICULTURE TO- TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS EFFORT.
TARGETED GRAZING- IS THE
APPLICATION OF A SPECIFIC KIND
AND CLASS OF LIVESTOCK AND A
DETERMINE SEASON. FOR DETERMINE
MOUNT OF TIME. ADDED A SPECIFIC
INTENSITY. TO ACCOMPLISH
VEGETATION OR LANDSCAPE LEVEL
GOALS. IT REFOCUSES WHAT WE DO
IS GRAZING FROM THE PRODUCTION
OF FOOD AND FIBER. TO DEALING
WITH VEGETATION ISSUES AND I
THINK THAT'S A REALY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION IT'LL COME BACK TO
IN A MOMENT. TARGETED GRAZING
CAN BE VERY EFFECTIVE IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTS AND IN SITUATIONS-
AS DR DALY SUGGESTED- GRAZING
IN WHILE AND PRESCRIBED FIRE
REALLY THE ONLY TOOLS IN OUR
TOOLBOX THAT REMOVE FUEL. ON
THE OTHER TOOL STILL THE FUEL
ON THE LANDSCAPE AND GRAZING
AND PRESCRIBED FIRE ARE UNIQUE
IN THAT IN THAT WAY. TYPICALLY
TARGETED GRAZING CAN BE VERY
COST EFFECTIVE WHERE OTHER
OPTIONS ARE INEFFECTIVE OR TOO
COSTLY. ON TRAINER TO PARKER
FEET IT'S TOO STEEP A REMOTE OR
ROCKY TO TREAT WITH WITH
EQUIPMENT OR WITH OTHER
TECHNIQUES- WE'RE FINDING IT.
ON AND IN A VARIETY OF PLACES
WHERE IT'S HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN
THAT WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
WHERE MAYBE WE CAN'T DO
PRESCRIBED FIRE BECAUSE OF THE
LIABILITY ISSUES WE CAN
CERTAINLY BRING. LIVESTOCK IN
AN ENTRY DOES FUEL LOADS AS
WELL. WE'RE ALSO FINDING THAT
IT'S EXTREMELY VALUABLE IN
MAINTAINING WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE TO CREATE FUEL BREAKS-
MORE WE'VE GONE IN AND DONE THE
INITIAL WORK PERHAPS
MECHANICALLY. BUT THEN WE CAN
USE LIVESTOCK TO MAINTAIN NOT
WORKING AND MAINTAIN THE FIRE
SAFETY OF THOSE LANDSCAPES. I
THINK THE KEY DISTINCTION HERE
IS THAT IT'S A SERVICE RATHER
THAN A PRODUCTION MODEL. AND AS
A SERVICE TAKES- HIGHLY
COMPETENT BUSINESS OWNERS AND
HIGHLY SKILLED LABOR TO
ACCOMPLISH WELL AND I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY KEY POINTS.
TARGETED GRAZING IS DIFFERENT
THAN A CONVENTIONAL
CONVENTIONAL PRODUCTION MODEL.
IN THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
VEGETATION. MY SHE BUSINESS I'M
FOCUSING ON MAKING SURE MY
SHEEP HAVE PROPER NUTRITION ALL
YEAR ROUND SO I GET AS MANY
LAMBS ON THE GROUND AS I CAN
WITH THE TARGETED GRAZING
BUSINESS WERE REALLY FOCUSED ON
MANAGING THAT BETTER TATIAN AND
SO TYPICALLY WE HAVE LOWER
REPRODUCTION RATES WE DON'T
HAVE THE PRODUCTS THAT WE HAVE
TO SELL IN A CONVENTIONAL
MODEL. AND I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO THINK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF HOW HOWTHIS-
PARTICULAR AFRICAN WORK.
GRAZING IS YOU CURRENTLY BEING
USED- AND DR DALY MENTIONED US
AS WELL YOU KNOW IT'S AN
ACTIVITY THAT'S BEEN HISTORIC
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. BUT
WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS GROWTH IN
TARGETED GRAZING AS A
PARTICULAR APPROACH TO THIS
ISSUE. IN THE LAST. FIVE YEARS.
WE'VE DOCUMENTED AT LEAST
THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WERE GRAZING IS
BEING USED AS A FUEL FOR
REDUCTION TECHNIQUE- COUNTIES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO- MARIN
COUNTY- NO SANDRA ELLER IS
USING GOATS I KNOW- WE'RE
SEEING IT BEING USED IN LOS
ANGELES AND TORRANCE AND DIEGO
COUNTIES. AND SO THERE'S THIS
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO USE IT IN
AREAS WHERE PERHAPS THERE HAVE
NOT BEEN- LIVESTOCK. PRODUCTION
FOR SOME TIME IN A ROLE
TARGETED MANNER. WE'RE ALSO
HEARING FROM FIRE AGENCIES THAT
IT WORKS- YOU KNOW CAL FIRE-
THROUGH THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
OVERSEAS CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED
A- PRESCRIBED YOUR BILL EVERY
WHITE PAPER THAT REALLY LAYS
OUT HOW THIS CAN WORK IN TERMS
OF FUEL REDUCTION. BUT MAYBE
MORE IMPORTANTLY IS THE
EVIDENCE ON THE GROUND HERE IN
THESE LAST SEVERAL YEARS- THE
HOPLAND RESEARCH EXTENSION
CENTER. WHICH UNIVERSITY HOUSE
UP NEAR YOU PRIOR. BECAUSE OF A
REALLY GRAPHIC EXAMPLE OF THE
CHANGE IN FIRE INTENSITY BASED
ON GRAZING VERSES ON NORTH NON.
NONPARTISAN LANDSCAPES- I'VE
TALKED WITH- THE PRODUCER THAT
WORKED IN MARIN COUNTY THIS
LAST YEAR THAT HEARD FROM.
FOLKS- WE'RE A FIRE STARTED AND
DIDN'T SPREAD INTO THE WILD
LAND BECAUSE OF THE GRAZING
THAT IT HAPPENED THERE. SO I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S THE PROOF
THAT THIS CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL- I THINK THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF THINGS REALLY FROM
LOOKING AT IT FROM KIND OF A- A
RESEARCH FROM AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STANDPOINT. WHERE
THERE MAY BE SOME OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE STATE TO ENCOURAGE MORE
OF THIS KIND OF WORK. CERTAINLY
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE DOING IT-
AND SO THE KIND OF CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN THE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION NECESSARY TO GET
PEOPLE UP TO SPEED ON THIS-
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION IS A
GREAT RESOURCE FOR SOME OF THAT
TRAINING BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS. IN EQUIPMENT AND
LIVESTOCK IN AND KNOW HOW TO
MAKE THIS WORK. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF FUEL REDUCTION COST
SHARE PROGRAMS ARE CHIEF
SCHUMER TALKED ABOUT SENATE
BILL NINE OH ONE WHICH PROVIDES
SOME MONEY- FOR FUELS REDUCTION
OVER THE NEXT. MAKERS FOR YEARS
LEFT IN THAT PROGRAM NOW IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY- THAT PROGRAM
COULD COULD REALLY FOCUS SOME
EFFORT ON CARSHARE FOR DOING
THIS KIND OF WORK- IT HAS
FOCUSED ON A NUMBER OF OTHER
FUELS REDUCTION ACTIVITIES BUT-
BUT TARGETED GRAZING. CAN AND
SHOULD BE A PART OF THAT- USDA
HAS THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
INCENTIVES PROGRAM THAT PAYS
CARSHARE FOR LANDOWNERS. AND
THEY ARE NOW IN CALIFORNIA
DOING CAR SHARE ON TARGETED
GRAZING WHICH I THINK IS
INCREDIBLY ENCOURAGING. AND
THEN I THINK THE LAST ISSUE
GETS TO THIS IDEA OF THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS NECESSARY
TO MAKE THIS WORK- MANY OF THE
CONTRACTS PARTICULARLY. IN MORE
THE URBAN AREAS DO REQUIRE
SOMEBODY ON SITE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. AND THROUGH- THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF AB
TEN SIXTY SIX WHICH WHICH DEALS
WITH ACT OVERTIME ISSUES- THERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES WITH THAT
WITH RESPECT TO SHEEPHERDERS.
THERE'S AN EASY FIX TO THAT IN
TERMS OF FEDERAL REGULATIONS
THAT WERE ADOPTED DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT THAT
DEAL WITH HURTING REGULATIONS
AND I THINK THAT'S A- THE PLACE
PERHAPS TO LOOK AT NOT BRINGING
FOR STATE PROGRAM IN LINE WITH
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AS WELL.
WITHOUT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THANK
YOU. REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR
TESTIMONY DAN- AND THE- ONE OF
BY OUR OUR OUR FINAL PANELIST
OF THE DAY TO SPEAK- CARA
HECKERT. CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST. I'M THE ONE
OUTLINES THE PREMEDITATION ALL
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON. THREE N.
AS THE ANCHOR I'M HAPPY TO SWIM
FASTER TODAY- SO THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN RIVAS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS CARA
HECKERT AND THE CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST I'M HAPPY TO SEE
THIS BIG CONTINGENCY FROM
CINEMA AND NAPA AND THE CINEMA
COUNTY RESIDENT AND A NAPA
VALLEY NATIVE. SO I HAVE A
EVACUATED THE LAST FIVE YEARS
HAVE MANY FRIENDS IN
AGRICULTURE WHO LOST THEIR
VINEYARDS AND THEIR BRANCHES
AND FRIENDS WHO LOST THEIR
HOMES. SO THIS IS CLOSE TO HOME
FOR ME- AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
IS A NATIONAL NONPROFIT. WE
LIKE TO SAY WE WORK FROM
KITCHEN TABLE TO CONGRESS ON
PROTECTING FARMLANDS
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND FARMING
PRACTICES. AND SUPPORTING A NEW
GENERATION OF FARMERS. BUT FOR
TODAY FOR THE NEXT FEW MINUTES
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE BENEFITS OF
PROTECTING OUR CALIFORNIA FARMS
AND RANCHES AS A WILDFIRE
MITIGATION STRATEGY. AM I THE
ONE FORTY NEEDS. ABOUT THE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS OUR
AGRICULTURAL LAND PROVIDES IS
OFTEN OVERLOOKED ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH ON GREENHOUSE GAS
MITIGATION OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
PROTECTING FARM AND RANCH LAND
IS LIKELY TO HAVE THE SINGLE
GREATEST IMPACT IN STABILIZING
AND REDUCING FUTURE EMISSIONS
ACROSS MULTIPLE LAND USES. I
OFTEN THINK IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE ARE BLESSED WITH SUCH
ABUNDANT AGRICULTURAL LAND THAT
WE FREQUENTLY TAKE FOR GRANTED
ALL THE BENEFITS THAT LAND
PROVIDES AND INCLUDING BEING A
CRITICAL TOOL IN COMBATING
CLIMATE CHANGE. NOT ONLY AS A
CARBON SINK BUT HOW IT CAN
MITIGATE FOR DISASTERS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES AMONG A HOST OF OTHER
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL BENEFITS. OKAY TWO
SEPARATE SETS OF RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATED THE CLEAR CLIMATE
BENEFITS THE PROTECTING
AGRICULTURAL LANDS HAS IN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THIS IS A INCLUDES
RESEARCH FROM ALWAYS JACKSON AT
UC DAVIS AND AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST. AFT RESEARCH FOUND THAT
AVERAGE EMISSIONS FROM URBAN
AREAS ARE FIFTY EIGHT TO
SEVENTY TIMES HIGHER PER ACRE
THAN THOSE FROM CROP PRODUCTION
IN CALIFORNIA. RELATED TO THIS
LOW DENSITY DEVELOPMENT
PRODUCES MORE GREENHOUSE GASES
PER CAPITA THAN EFFICIENT HIGH
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT. URBAN
EXPANSION ESPECIALLY LOW
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT RESULTS IN
THE IRREPLACEABLE LOSS OF FAR
MORE FARMLAND THE NECESSARY.
OUR RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT
CUTTING FARMLAND LOST BY 75% BY
TWENTY FIFTY WOULD REDUCE OUR
GHG EMISSIONS EQUIVALENT OF
TAKING ONE POINT NINE MILLION
CARS OFF THE ROAD EACH YEAR.
PROTECTING FARMLAND WHILE
GROWING CITIES IN A COMPACT
MATTER WOULD HAVE THIRTY THREE
TONS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS PER ACRE PER YEAR
WHEN COMPARED TO SPRAWL
DEVELOPMENT. THIS TYPE OF
EFFICIENT DEVELOPMENT
STABILIZES AND REDUCES FUTURE
EMISSIONS WHILE STILL ALLOWING
THE STATE ECONOMY TO EXPAND.
AND HOUSING GOALS TO BE
ACHIEVED. IT'S NOT WHETHER WE
NEED TO GROW ITS HOW WE GROW.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERING CALIFORNIA'S GOAL
OF REDUCING STATEWIDE GHG
EMISSIONS BY 80% BY TWENTY
FIFTY. SAYS MANY FOLKS HAVE
SAID BEFORE AGAS TRULY PART OF
THE SOLUTION AND COMBATING
CLIMATE CHANGE. IN ADDITION AND
YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF THE FROM
THE FROM THE PRIOR SPEAKERS.
AGRICULTURAL LAND TO
SUSTAINABLY MANAGE FARM AND
RANCH LAND PROVIDES A HOST OF
ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS. BUT THEY
ALSO PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP WITH WILDFIRE PREVENTION
SOMETIMES WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT AS DIRECTLY AS IT ACTUALLY
IS. IRRIGATED CROPLAND JUST
LIKE IN THE CASE OF CINEMA
COUNTY CAN BE UTILIZED AS A
FIRE BREAK. INCREASED WATER
SUPPLIES FROM GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE ZONES CAN INCREASE
FIRE FOR FIRE PREVENTION. AND
CLEARLY WHEN WE USE MORE
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES. I AM IT'S SMART
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES HEALTHY
SOILS PRACTICES. WE ARE ABLE TO
MULTIPLY THAT BENEFITS MANY
TIMES OVER. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO BOTH. NOT ALL
REMAINING FARMLAND IS IDEAL FOR
AGRICULTURE HOWEVER SOMETIMES
CONSIDERED A CONTROVERSIAL
STATEMENT TO SAY THAT BUT
STRESS ON WATER SUPPLIES
UNSUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND UNFORESEEN
TEMPERATURE AND CLIMATE CHANGE
DEPLETE THE AVAILABILITY OF
HIGH QUALITY FARMLAND IN
CALIFORNIA. THEREFORE
PROTECTING THE BEST FARMLAND
THAT'S LEFT THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
VERSATILE AND RESILIENT IS
PARAMOUNT. AND THAT BRINGS ME
TO WHERE WE'RE AT NOW. OVER THE
PAST THREE DECADES MORE THAN
ONE MILLION ACRES OF CALIFORNIA
FARMLAND HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
AGRICULTURE. REPRESENTING A
DEVASTATING LOSS AND
AGRICULTURAL CAPACITY. EACH
YEAR CALIFORNIA LOSES THE
AVERAGE OF FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
OF AGRICULTURAL LAND THE
EQUIVALENT OF MORE THAN ONE AND
A HALF TIMES THE AREA OF SAN
FRANCISCO. HALF OF THIS LOSS IS
TAKING PLACE ON THE STATE'S
MOST PRODUCTIVE FARMLAND WHICH
IS OFTEN LOCATED AT THE URBAN
EDGE WHERE IT'S MOST VULNERABLE
TO THE EFFECTS. OF URBAN SPRAWL.
IF THAT CURRENT DEVELOPMENT
TREND CONTINUES ANOTHER ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION ACRES WILL
BE LOST BY MID CENTURY. USING A
FARMLAND CONSERVATION SCENARIO
WHICH IS IN GREEN. WHICH IS
THAT THIS IS THE MODEL FROM
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST. IF WE
SUSTAIN FUNDING FOR STATE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS A STABLE
ADVANCE CONSERVATION PROGRAM
THROUGH DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION. AND CALIFORNIA
FARM LAND CONSERVANCY PROGRAM
AND ADOPT LOCAL M. AG LAND
MITIGATION AND OTHER PROTECTION
POLICIES. THAT'S WHERE WE CAN
STEM THE LOSS OF FARMLAND. WE
KNOW FROM RECENT RESEARCH BY
CALIFORNIA RANGELANDS TRUSTS.
THAT THEIR APPROVING ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THAT. THAT THE
ECOSYSTEMS SERVICE SERVICES
PROVIDE ONE PROTECTED. THE
RECENT STUDY SAID JUST A LITTLE
OVER OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES THAT THEY HAVE
EASEMENT ON PROVIDES ONE
BILLION DOLLARS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS ANNUALLY.
MORE SPECIFICALLY AG LAND
PROTECTION IS KEY TO HELPING US
MITIGATE FOR INCREASED NATURAL
DISASTERS SUCH AS WILDFIRES.
BUT THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT OF
THAT MEDICATION IS A LITTLE
KNOWN OR QUANTIFIED. AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK THAT
WE REALLY COULD WORK WITH ALL
OF YOU ON HOW DO WE QUANTIFY
THE BENEFITS THAT ALL THESE
THINGS ARE PROVIDING. IT IS NO
DOUBT EXPONENTIALLY GREATER
IMPACT. SO IN CLOSING. I GREW
CULTURAL LAND PROTECTION CAN
PROVIDE MULTIPLE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION OPPORTUNITIES AND
PROVIDE A SERIES OF CO BENEFITS
IT'S CRITICAL TO MAINTAIN STATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS TO PROTECT OUR
AGRICULTURAL LAND AND ALSO TO
HELP MANAGE THEM RESPONSIBLY.
AND WITH THAT I'LL CLOSE THANK
YOU. MISS PARKER THANK YOU SO
MUCH WELCOME TO. GET
INFORMATION THE- FIVE QUESTIONS
FOR THIS PANEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- LET MY QUESTION
IS GO TO- MISTER MAKAN- YOU'D
MENTIONED- SB NINE A ONE FUNDS
WITH CAL FIRE IN. ALL OF THAT-
COULD YOU GIVE US SOME SOME
NUMBERS ON YOU KNOW ACRE
DEGREES TO WHERE- IN THEN THE
COST OF THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS
WE CAN HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE TO SCALE.
ABSOLUTELY THEN I HAVE A
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
WHAT YOU HAD MENTIONED WITH THE
HIGHLY SKILLED LABOR AS WELL
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. WITH
RESPECT TO THE COST OF DOING
THIS KIND OF WORK IN CANADA THE
NUMBER OF ACRES GRAZED I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO GET- AN INVENTORY ON
OURSELVES WITHIN UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION. ON THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME EFFORTS TO MATCH GRAZER'S
UP WITH PLACES THAT NEED NEED
THAT SERVICE THE RACE FOR
DOING THAT WORK REALLY VERY BY
THE TYPE OF TERRAIN AND BY ON
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE OF THE
PROJECT INVOLVED. WE'RE SEEING
THOSE RATES RANGE FROM AROUND
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
AN ACRE. AND A LARGER SCALE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE PROJECTS. TO
UPWARDS OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS
AN ACRE WERE IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GET ANIMALS IN SAFELY AND- IN
TO DO THE KIND OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. BUT THAT THAT
ALSO DID VERY IS DEPENDS RIGHT
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL OF RISK
AND- COMPLEXITY WITH SOME OF
THE MORE URBAN SITES THAT FOLKS
ARE WORKING IN TWO. OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN- YOU'D MENTIONED
WITH THE- ON THE LABOR SIDE-
SOME OF THE FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
THE WILL YOU PLEASE EXPAND ON
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT- CARVE
OUTS FOR OTHER THINGS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON OVER
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
SO. I THINK IT WOULD HELP THE
COMMITTEE AND ALL OF US TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THIS.
HIGHLY SKILLED WORK FORCE IN
AND EXACTLY HOW THIS WORKS
BECAUSE THEY ARE. ON SITE YOU
KNOW TWENTY FOUR SEVEN- YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES SOME OF THESE
ERRORS ARE A REALLY REMOTE AND
HARD TO GET TO SO IT ARE NOT
EXACTLY ON A NORMAL EIGHT TO
FIVE O'CLOCK- SO PLEASE EXPAND.
ABSOLUTELY AND ERIC YOU KNOW
ANY ANY ANYBODY THAT'S BEEN
AROUND LIVESTOCK KNOWS THAT-
THAT THEY DON'T PUNCH A CLOCK
EITHER AND SO THE WORK. THE
WORK NEEDS TO HAPPEN- WHEN IT'S
IN FRONT OF US WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE- THERE
HAS BEEN- A FEDERAL PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES FOR. SHEEPHERDERS
AND GROCERS IN PARTICULAR WHO
ARE WORKING IN THESE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS- WHILE THEY ARE.
LIVING AND WORKING. WITH THAT
WITH THAT PARTICULAR OPERATION.
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM RECOGNIZES
THAT THEY WORK A FORTY EIGHT
HOUR WORK WEEK- CALIFORNIA HAS
TAKEN A DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT THAT
WORK WEEK ENTAILS AND THAT'S
WHERE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. OF THE OF AB TEN
SIXTY SIX COME INTO PLAY- UNDER
CALIFORNIA DEFINITION- IT'S A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT HOUR
WORK WEEK. AND SO ONCE THAT
THAT LEGISLATION IS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED- THE INITIAL YEAR
OF THAT WOULD INCREASE COSTS BY
OVER 60% AND. AND GO UP FROM
THERE- WITH IN THE- PROGRAM IT
IS MORE IN LINE WITH THE ACTUAL
WORK THAT IS BEING DONE ON THE
LANDSCAPE AND SO THAT
PARTICULAR. DEFINITION IN TERMS
OF FORTY EIGHT HOURS IS ALSO
MORE IN LINE WITH WARY BE
TURNED SIXTY SIX- WOULD BE
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AS WELL.
SO WOULD WOULD YOU SEE THAT AS
SOMETHING WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
ASK THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ADJUST TO HAVE THEM LOOK AT IT.
YOU KNOW FOR THE INSTANCES OF.
THESE TYPES ARE HEARD IN THIS
TYPE OF WORK FORCE. TO FOLLOW
THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES VERSUS
THE STATE GUIDELINES I MEAN HOW
HOW. HOW WOULD WE NEED TO GO
ABOUT FIXING THAT TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
USE- IN IN CONTINUE USE OF THIS
TYPE OF FIRE MITIGATION SO THAT
WAY THIS DOESN'T. END UP
LEAVING THE STATE LIKE OTHER
THINGS. SO THE- INITIAL
CALIFORNIA INTERPRETATION WAS
MADE ADMINISTRATIVELY AND SO IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT- THIS
THIS NEW ADMINISTRATIVE
DETERMINATION TO BRING
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY IN LINE
WITH THE FEDERAL
INTERPRETATION. WHAT COULD BE
DONE TO ADMINISTRATIVELY IT
WOULD NOT NOT THEIRS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT REQUIRE
LEGISLATION TO BE ACCOMPLISHED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LEVINE
QUESTION. YEAH YOU MIGHT WANNA
TAKE A SEAT. THANK YOU. BUT
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW. EVEN ON ZOOM
I STILL HAVE IT ON IT ALL THE
TIME SO YOU'D MENTION THE USE
OF THE SHEEP AND REALLY WE'VE
SEEN IT IN- KIND OF THE MORE
DEVELOPED AREAS WHICH WHEN I
TALK TO IT'S A FIREFIGHTING
PROFESSIONALS AND THAT'S REALLY
THE RISK IS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
THESE MASSIVE EVENTS THAT DO
OCCUR AND HAVE REALLY HURT THE
NORTH BAY AND OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THE RISK IS
THESE. DEVELOPED AREAS HOUSE TO
HOUSE MEMBERS WHICH WE'VE SEEN
IN THE BIG BIG EVENTS BUT BUT
CERTAINLY HAPPENS ON EVERYDAY
BASIS AND- AND THAT THE THAT
THE SHEEP IN THE WORK THAT THEY
DO PROTECT AGAINST- THAT
SPREADING MORE MASSIVELY IS
WE'VE WE'VE SEEN AND I THINK
THERE TO REALLY GREAT EXTENT IN
A BIG FIRE SITUATION IT WAS
ILLUSTRATED- IN CINEMA CLOSE TO
SAN PABLO BAY NEAR THIS THE
CINEMA RACEWAY- WHERE- WHAT
COULD HAVE BEEN A REALLY
DEVASTATING EVENT AND CERTAINLY
WAS THROUGHOUT MUCH OF THE
NORTH BAY THAT NIGHT'S- WAS
ABLE TO YOU KNOW FIGHT BACK
THAT FIRE. PROBABLY BECAUSE OF
THE WORK THAT SHE HAD DONE OVER
MANY YEARS. AND IT WAS A IT WAS
A REALLY POSITIVE DEMONSTRATION
OF THE POWER. OF THAT OF USING
SHEEP IN THIS WAY. HAVE YOU
SEEN UN GROWTH OR EVEN OVER
SUBSCRIPTION AND WHAT IS THE
CHALLENGE TO SCALE IF THERE IS
DEMAND FOR THAT- IN THE STATE
IS BIGGEST CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
SEEING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
GROWTH- IN THAT BOTH IN TERMS
OF EXISTING OPERATIONS THAT ARE
ARE KIND OF EXPANDING WHAT THEY
DO IN THAT REGARD IN AND
FRANKLY NEW OPERATIONS GETTING
INTO THE BUSINESS. I THINK ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES ARM AS WE
GROW THAT SEGMENT OF THE OF THE
GRAZING BUSINESS IS TO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCE IN AND KNOWLEDGE
NECESSARY TO DO IT EFFECTIVELY
AND SAFELY- PARTICULARLY IN A
MORE URBAN LANDSCAPE- IT'S ONE
THING TO BE TO BE GRAZING SHEEP
OR I DO WHERE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND. IT'S ANOTHER THING TO
BE MANAGING LIVESTOCK IN AN
AREA WHERE THERE'S- THOUSANDS
ARE IF NOT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AND ALL THE POTENTIAL
FOR CONFLICT THAT GOES WITH
THAT. I THINK- I THINK THE
OTHER OPPORTUNITY IN THAT
REGARD THAT THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO FOCUS ON IS WE'VE GOT THIS
WINDOW WHERE WE NEED TO TREAT
FUELS- YOU KNOW FROM STARTING
IN THE SOUTH MAYBE IN FEBRUARY
ON UP INTO JUNE AND JULY AND
AUGUST UP UP IN THIS PART OF
THE STATE- BUT THAT STILL
LEAVES SEVERAL MONTHS WHERE
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO FEED
THOSE LIVESTOCK OTHER PLACES.
AND SO BEING ABLE TO COORDINATE
THAT WERE WE'VE GOT WINTER
GRAZING- TO MAINTAIN THOSE
KINDS OF FLOCKS AND HERDS I
THINK IS A ANOTHER CHALLENGE
FOR US IN AND IS FAR AS
MANAGING AND HOUSING THERE
HEARD ARE THEY IN RESIDENTS FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN THEY
GET ON THAT TRAILER GO TO THE
NEXT JOB OR THEY GO BACK OUT TO
TAMALA SPARE OF THE PLASTER AND
GO BACK TO WHERE THEY WOULD
LIVE IN IN THEIR OFF SEASON IF
YOU WILL OR IS THERE A CONSTANT
STREAM OF WORK BECAUSE THEY'VE
GOT IT ALL THE TIME ANYHOW.
THEY ABSOLUTELY THEY DON'T YOU
DON'T SHUT THEM OFF AND PUT HIM
IN THE SHED WHEN THEY'RE DONE
WORK AND- I THINK WHAT WE WHAT
WE ARE SAYING IS THAT THAT WERE
KIND OF REBUILDING THE OLD-
PNEUMATIC SYSTEM OF LIVESTOCK
GRAZING IN THAT THESE FLOCKS
AND HERDS ARE TYPICALLY ON
TARGETED GRAZING PROJECTS FROM
FEBRUARY THROUGH MAYBE
SEPTEMBER- AND THEN TYPICALLY
THEY'LL GO TO A HOME RANCHER
HOME BASE- KIND OF. GET YOU
KNOW DO ALL THAT THE HEALTH
WORK THAT THEY NEED TO DO WITH
THEIR ANIMALS- RECUPERATE FROM
BEING ON THE ROAD BUT THEY'RE
GOING FROM PROJECT TO PROJECT
THERE ARE HARD SHEEP AND GOATS
THAT'LL BE IN PLASTER COUNTY IN
FEBRUARY AND MARCH THAT WILL
THEN COME DOWN TO YOUR PART OF
THE WORLD- LATER IN THE YEAR
AND KIND OF JUST CONTINUING
MAKE THAT CIRCUIT. GRATEFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I HAVE A
QUESTION FROM A SOCCER. RIGHT
FROM THE BACK OF THE ROOM.
THANK YOU IT'S REALLY NICE TO
SEE YOU I'M NOT MY QUESTION WAS
THE TREND LINES ON
CONSERVATION- AND CONVERSION
AND- IN AND LOOKS LIKE YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES FOR AN IMPORTANT
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND EVEN. FIRE BREAKS AND FIRE
PREVENTION- AND EVEN AYE I
WOULD TAKE IT TO ANOTHER LEVEL
OUR OPPORTUNITY SET THAT CARBON
SEQUESTRATION- BECAUSE OF LAND
MANAGEMENT TOOLS THAT WE CAN
USE TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT-
D. THE TREND LINES DON'T TELL
US WHERE THIS IS OCCURRING.
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND- AND HOW- IT.
WHETHER THIS IS A CANTON LIKE
APPROACH PIECEMEAL APPROACH TO
IT TO THIS CONVERSION OR IF IT
THERE IS A SOME TYPE OF THE
PHYSICAL- YOU KNOW GEOGRAPHICAL
STRATEGY OF WE'RE OR NOT TRAGIC
THAT RATIONALE FOR WHY CERTAIN
LAND IS COMING OUT OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION AND-
AND WITH IT AND IF ON A MAP.
THAT WOULD DEMONSTRATE TO US
WHERE IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO-
IN VANCE- AGRICULTURAL LAND
PROTECTIONS- BECAUSE OF THE
RISK OF- OF DESTROYING WHAT
COULD POTENTIALLY BE. BOTH
AGRICULTURALLY IMPORTANT LAND
ENVIRONMENTALLY IMPORTANT LAND
BUT ALSO FROM A FIRE BREAK
PERSPECTIVE- OPENING THAT UP AS
WELL AND TO TALK ABOUT WHETHER
THERE'S DATA TO SUPPORT. I'VE
GOT MAPS I'VE GOTTA. I JUST
AHEAD FIVE MINUTE YEAH. I HAD-
THERE'S NO. IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY- SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND A HALF
T. DID A NATIONAL REPORT CALLED
FARMING ON THE EDGE- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT IN
PARTICULAR THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. WAS IN THE TOP TEN IN
THE IN THE NATION AND ACTUALLY
THAT'S WHY WE ESTABLISHED OUR
FIRST OFFICE IN VISALIA. BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO WERE NOT
THERE ANYMORE- BUT- YEAH AND I
WOULD ALSO SAY OF PORTIONS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THOSE ARE
THE THAT THE TWO THAT ARE
ALWAYS AT THE TOP- OTHER
REGIONS IS IT KIND OF A COUNTY
BY COUNTY. BASIS OBVIOUSLY
LOCAL LAND USE POLICY AND HOW
THAT IS- SUPPORTED. PLAYS A BIG
ROLE IN FARMLAND LOSS AND ALSO
THE ECONOMICS OF THE AREA I
MEAN IT IF THERE'S A CITY OR A
TOWN THAT NEEDS TO DEVELOP TO
KEEP THEIR ECONOMIC ENGINE
GOING AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INCENTIVES. TO STAY IN FARMING
AND FARMERS DON'T HAVE A
SUCCESSOR AND THEY NEED TO SELL
TO A DEVELOPER BECAUSE THAT'S
THEIR MAIN OPTION SO THERE'S
MANY MANY FACTORS BUT WE COULD
CERTAINLY HELP YOU- PRIORITIZE.
IF THAT WOULD BE NEEDED BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO SAVE ALL THE FARM LAND
THAT WE HAVE AND- IN THE LOSS
IN CONVERGENCE COULD BE RETAIL
HOUSING DORMANCY ANY NUMBER OF
OTHER REASONS TO YEAH. REALLY
RURAL RANCH THAT'S- ARE THE
NUMBER ONE LOW DENSITY HOUSING
I WE ACTUALLY HAVE A NEW I.
REPORT THAT CAME OUT THIS YEAR
CALLED FARMS UNDER THREAT. AND
IT DEFINITELY IS LOW DENSITY.
SPRAWL MORE THAN URBAN DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME GREAT TO
FEEL. GREAT QUESTIONS
APPRECIATE THE- THE DIALOGUE
AND RESPONSES- THIS. AT THIS
POINT AN INTEREST OF TIME WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO- TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IF. WE HAVE MEMBERS OF
THE AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SOME PUBLIC COMMENTS
YOU'RE LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES
YOU'RE WELCOME. TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. BECAUSE STATE YOUR
NAME AND- WHERE FROM WOULD BE
HELPFUL. HI MY NAME IS SANDRA
HAD STRONG AND- I ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY- BUT THIS TOPIC OF FIRES
IS OF PARTICULAR INTEREST TO ME
BECAUSE I WAS LIVING IN SONOMA
COUNTY IN THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA WHEN THE TUBBS FIRE
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES IN
OCTOBER SEVENTEEN. AS A RESULT
OF TUBS ME AND MY FAMILY OF SIX
INCLUDING MY FOUR CHILDREN WERE
DISPLACED AND WERE FORCED TO
MOVE TO SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M
I'M ACTUALLY A GOAT FARMERS
WELL. THREE OF MY CHILDREN
ACTUALLY GAVE TESTIMONY
RECENTLY HERE IN THIS BUILDING
AND HEARING ABOUT USING.
CONTROLLED BURNS TO CONTROL.
AND MANAGE FIRE UP FIRES.
LISTEN MY CHILDREN GAVE
TESTIMONY IT WAS A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT THING FOR ME A COUPLE
OF WEEKS BACK AS IT BROUGHT UP
THE HORRORS OF THOSE DAYS AND
THE WEEKS THAT OUR SANTA ROSA
COMMUNITY AND TOWARD. BECAUSE
THAT WAS SUCH AN INTENSE-
HEARING FOR ME I ASKED A FRIEND
TO JOIN YOU TODAY FOR MORAL
SUPPORT. SO I INVITED A FRIEND
FROM SHASTA COUNTY TODAY TO
JOIN ME IN THIS HEARING BECAUSE
HIS AREA HAS ALSO BEEN HARD HIT
WITH FIRES AS WELL INCLUDING
MOST RECENTLY WITH THE DOG FIRE
WHERE TWO OF HIS NEIGHBORS DIED
A MOTHER AND HER EIGHT YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER OF A FAMILY OF FIVE.
BUT MY FRIEND IS NOT HERE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE HE WAS PREVENTED
FROM RE ENTERING THE BUILDING
THIS AFTERNOON BECAUSE HE HAD
NOT COVERED HIS NOSE WITH HIS
MASK DURING THE MORNING HEARING
AND APPARENTLY THAT QUALIFIES
HIM AS BEING BANISHED FROM THE
BUILDING SOMEHOW. SO I'M
STANDING HERE RIGHT NOW AS HIS
PROXY TRYING TO GIVE TESTIMONY
OF THE HEARTBREAKING LOSS THAT
HIS NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS IN
TOWARD WHEN TWO MEMBERS OF A
FIVE MEMBER FAMILY DIED IN THIS
AUG FIRE THE MOTHER AND THE
EIGHT YEAR OLD GIRL. AND I'M
HONESTLY WONDERING RIGHT AT THE
MOMENT WHAT KIND OF THE
UNIVERSE I'M LIVING IN BECAUSE
MY FRIEND IN SUPPORT PERSON WHO
DROVE HOURS AND HUNDREDS OF
MILES IN FACT TO JOIN ME TODAY
GOT KICKED OUT OF PARTICIPATORY
GOVERNMENT FOR NOT COVERING HIS
NOSE. WHEN HIS DESIRE TO BE IN
THIS BUILDING WAS DUE TO
WANTING TO GIVE TESTIMONY OF
THE TRAGIC PREVENTABLE DEATH OF
A FRIEND AND HER EIGHT YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER IN YET ANOTHER OF
THESE CRIMINAL FIRES. SO COULD
I HAVE TWO MORE MINUTES TO READ
WHAT HE HAD PLANNED TO READ
ABOUT THESE PEOPLE THAT DIED
PLEASE. BECAUSE COVER HIS NOSE.
OKAY IF YOU WANT TO USE THE TWO
MINUTES. I'M FINE WITH THAT WE
NOW KNOW THE IDENTITY OF THE
REMAINING TWOS AUG FIRE VICTIMS
JUST FROM SEPTEMBER A MOTHER
AND A DAUGHTER WHO LIVED ON
ARCHER ROAD A LAND IN THE CLOUD
AND HER DAUGHTER EIGHT YEAR OLD
FEY LOWER AT THEIR HOME THE DAY
THE FIRE BROKE OUT. THE DAY OF
THE FIRE ROB SUSIE AND ZAC WERE
OUT OF CELL SERVICE COLLECTING
LADY BUGS FOR THEIR COMPANY
WELL LANA AND FEY LOWER ON
THEIR HOME ON ARCHER ROAD THIS
AUG FIRE WAS RAGING SO FAST
ARCHER ROAD PEOPLE WERE
SCRAMBLING TO GET OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE A LAN AND
FEHLER TRIED TO ESCAPE. AND
WE'RE DRIVING OUT OF THE FIRE
BUT THE SMOKE WAS SO THICK YOU
COULDN'T EVEN SEE THEIR HAND IN
FRONT OF THEIR FACE. IN THE
DEBT ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD
BUT- I NEED TO REMEMBER FOUND.
SO WE DID NOT MAKE IT OUT ROB
STUDENTS ACTED WAITED NEARLY
TWENTY FOUR HOURS WONDERING
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE GIRLS
BEFORE THE CORONER TOLD THEM
THE NEWS A FULL DAY LATER AND I
ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES BECAUSE
ALL I GOT OUT ALIVE. I'M ONE OF
THE LUCKY ONES BECAUSE MY
FAMILY GOT OUT ALIVE. AND I'M
SITTING HERE LISTENING TO THIS
WONDERING. CALL ME SKEPTICAL
BUT WHAT YOU THE LEGISLATURE
WHATWILL YOU END UP DOING SET
UP ANOTHER TASK FORCE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE ADD TO THE CALIFORNIA
CARBON PLAN HIRE MORE ASK
EXPERTS WITH OUR MONEY WHEN YOU
UP SO OBVIOUSLY FAILED US WITH
YOUR POLICIES UP UNTIL NOW AND
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO JUST SIT
BACK AND TRUST YOU SORRY I
DON'T FOR ONE MOMENT. IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THIS HEARING IS
HAPPENING DECADES TOO LATE FROM
THE ONGOING CORRUPTION WITH THE
CPUC AND YOUR RADICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES
INCLUDING YOUR TIES TO PG&E NOT
TO MENTION YOUR BLOOD MONEY
CONNECTIONS TO A CONVICTED
FELON POWER MONOPOLY PG&E I DO
NOT TRUST. TO MANAGER WITH THE
FIRE ISSUE MEMOS TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU COULD TAKE YOUR
NAME AND WHERE YOU RESIDE
PLEASE. INTERVIEW I GOT MAJOR
MINUTES FEDERAL BANK- I SHOULD
SAY I HAPPEN TO SPEAK WITH THE
OFFICE- I SHOULD SAY HOW MUCH I
ADMIRE THE COURAGE I HAVE YOU
KNOW IN OUR STATE THE A
PRACTICAL WISDOM YOU'LL HAVE.
IN A- BUT THE AUTHORITY HAVING
THIS ROOM OF OURS. THE- CLARITY
OF RATIONALE A CLARITY OF
THINKING THAT YOU ARE A
PROVIDER SINCE. MANDA IN
SACRAMENTO I- I CAN HEAR THAT
MANY. COSTS ACTUALLY ALSO THAT
I MARK OUR DEMOCRACY SOME
PRETTY MUCH. AND AND I FEEL
LIKE I GOVERNMENTS FEEL GOOD
DECENT PEOPLE I THINK THAT'S
WHY THEY ARE IN THE JOB THEY DO
I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH GOOD THINGS
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO. WHO ARE
ELECTED THERE'S THAT HAD PUT
ME. IN THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
SENTIMENT SEMINAL COUNTY- I CAN
HEAR THE MANY OF YOU HAVE YOU
ALL HAVE EXPERIENCE REAL LOSS I
DON'T DOUBT THAT YOU HAVE HURTS
IN YOUR HEARTS AND I DON'T
DOUBT THAT YOU WISH THE PAIN.
WOULD GO AWAY. AND IT WON'T.
BUT SOON NAY. IT'S A REAL
HORROR IN CALIFORNIA. I HEARD
THE STORY FARMER. WHO'S CAL WAS
BURNED. WHEN SHE WAS PREGNANT
AND THE BABY CALF. WITH
RUNNING. CYCLING HER MOTHER IN
SPIRIT WITH. HI I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FIRES THE
MOST CONCERN ABOUT FIRES
BURNING OUR STATE CALLED
BIOTECHNOLOGY OR NANOTECHNOLOGY
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED. BECAUSE
OF MY LIFE PERSONALLY AND IT'S
NOT IMPORTANT BECAUSE I'VE
BASICALLY BEEN. HAS NOT CLOSER
BUT I'VE BEEN TORTURED FOR
ELEVEN STRAIGHT SIX ONE
STRAIGHT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FIVE
MONTHS STRAIGHT TORMENT AND YOU
KNOW I HAVE A POLICE REPORT
FROM THE SX SERVICE DEPARTMENT
TALK ABOUT HOW I HAD YOU KNOW
PEOPLE BRINGS MY APARTMENT PUT
CHEMICALS ON MY FLOOR CHEMICALS
OFF MY VEHICLE. TOPPLED DRUG ON
MY DOORKNOB THAT YOU KNOW WAS
THAT IT WAS SOME KIND OF BRAIN
VIRUS AND I YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
POURING SOME NOBODY SPECIAL
INTERESTS I'M NOBODY BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS
OPERATED THESE KIND OF THINGS
THAT HAPPEN TO CHILDREN NOT NOT
WAS HAVING ME. BUT ANYTHING AT
ALL LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENED WE
COULD HAVE YOUR TALKS WHEN I
JUST WANT TO KNOW DO YOU
REALIZE HOW SERIOUS THIS IS.
I'M NOT HERE TO BLAME ANYONE I
FEEL LIKE WE YEAH I HAVE
COMPASSION FOR EVERYONE I FEEL
LIKE THAT'S WHAT IS GOING TO
BRING US THROUGH. YOU KNOW I
FEEL LIKE CHILDREN THE BEATING
THE MEDICINE LOVE OUR LIVES I
FEEL LIKE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
EVERYTHING TO US ALL OF US SO
WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THAT. I
DON'T WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME IF YOU COULD WRAP UP IN
THE NEXT. TWENTY SECONDS.
THAT'S TWO MINUTES. I FEEL THE-
RESPONSE. FOR CAN PER. I FEEL
LIKE WE CAN WORK. TO MAKE THIS.
BECAUSE ALL OF US. WHOEVER'S
CAN PROVIDE. SCHOOLS WITH RAW
ANIMAL ORGANS. FROM SHEEP AND
PIGS AND COWS BECAUSE OF
ENZYMES CAN IMPEDE THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE STATIC BIO
AND- CHEMICAL. NANO DEVICES.
THEY CAN ALSO PROVIDE METAL
BARS OF APPROXIMATELY LARGE
ENOUGH REACH COMMUNITIES
CHILDREN. THANK YOU SIR. THEY
CAN PROVIDE PEOPLE CAN I GET A
VERY PROMINENT IN CUSTODY
WITHIN SUCH AS WELL BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO. PROSECUTORS
ALL INFORMATION ASK. OUR
PERHAPS. WHAT I'M TRYING. TO
REMEMBER GRADUATION PROCESS. IF
THERE ARE A MEMBERS IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO LIKE TO MAKE
COMMENTS A GALA TO ME NOW THE
TIME TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS. IF
YOU STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT
WAY FROM FOR THE RECORD PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT MEETING
TODAY AT SHINING SOME LIGHT ON
THE IMPACTS OF THESE DEATHS
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES TO
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS. MY NAME IS KIRK
WILDER I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED CATTLE
RANCHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING OF
COURSE DOCTOR DAVE DALY WHO YOU
HEARD FROM EARLIER. I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT THE IMPACTS
THAT YOU HEARD FROM DAVE ALL
DEVASTATING ARE NOT UNIQUE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE
HEARD SIMILAR DEVASTATION ABOUT
RANGELAND BURNING UP. HERS
BURNING UP- AND LOSING FIFTH OR
SIXTH GENERATION RANCHING
LEGACIES IN THE STATE FROM THE
CREEK FIRE RESCUE FIRE THREE
AUGUST COMPLEX FIRES AND ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BUT WE'RE
NOT REALLY HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF TWENTY
TWENTY ON AGRICULTURE WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
PREVENT. TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIRE
SEASON ARE. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SEASON FROM HAPPENING AGAIN. I
WANT UNDERSCORE THAT CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION. ARE
RANGERS AND RANGERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. ARE EAGER TO PARTNER
WITH YOU ON FINDING THOSE
SOLUTIONS THIS YEAR. ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE STATE THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION ACRES. ARE RANGELANDS
THEY'RE OWNED OR MANAGED BY
RANCHERS- WE HEARD FROM DAVID
FROM DAN MAKING TODAY THERE'S
BASICALLY. TWO ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS TO REDUCING FIRE
FUELS FROM THE LANDSCAPE. THAT
IS GRAYSON. HAS PRESCRIBED
FIRE. WE'VE PROVIDED YOU A
LETTER IN YOUR COMMITTEE
PACKAGE DATA TALKS ABOUT SOME
THIRTY THOUSAND FORTY. FIVE
PERSPECTIVES ON HOW WE CAN GO
ABOUT. INCREASING PRESCRIBED
FIRE ON THE LANDSCAPE
INCREASING GRAZING ON THE
LANDSCAPE IN THE COMING
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. WE'RE
EAGER TO PARTNER WITH YOU ON
FINDING THOSE SOLUTIONS. ARE
REAL QUICK I JUST WANT TO DIG A
LITTLE DEEPER ON THOSE TWO
ISSUES. WE'D LIKE TO SEE
INCREASED GRAZING ON STATE
LANDS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS LIMITED
GRAZING ON STATE PARKS AND DFW
LAMBS- BUT BECAUSE GRAZING CAN
BE USED TO REDUCE THOSE FINE
FUEL LOADS. WE'D LIKE TO SEE AN
EXPANDED. ADDITIONALLY YOU
KNOW. PRESCRIBED FIRES GOING TO
BE A KEY TOOL. FIVE TO SOLVING
OUR WILDFIRE ISSUES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT THE
BIGGEST ISSUE WE'VE SEEN FROM
OUR FIRE EXPERTS WE CONSULTED
ARE FAR SUBCOMMITTEE. IS THE
ISSUE OF LIABILITY. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS A- SIMPLE
NEGLIGENCE LIABILITY FOR SIDES
PRESCRIBED BURNS WE'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT CHANGE TO PERHAPS A
GROSS NEGLIGENCE STANDARD.
AGAIN THERE ARE FURTHER.
OPPORTUNITIES OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER TO YOU AND CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION. AND
OUR MEMBERS STATEWIDE ARE EAGER
TO PARTNER WITH YOU. ON FINDING
FIRE SOLUTIONS IN THE COMING
YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE COMMENTS ANYONE ELSE. FOR
PUBLIC. COMMENTS LIMITED TWO
MINUTES. TO HAVE TO CHECK.
PHONE LINES IF THERE'S NO OKAY.
SO WITH THAT I DON'T SEE THE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO GET PROMISE I DO
WANNA THANK VICE CHAIR MATHIS
FOR MAKING TIME TO BE HERE WITH
US THIS AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE. I KNOW OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYWOMAN CECILIA
AGUILAR CURRY I INTENDED TO BE
HERE SHE HAD A CONFLICT ON HER
CALENDAR. BUT I CERTAINLY THINK
ALL OF OUR- MEMBERS THAT. THAT
DISSIPATED ON OUR PANELS- THIS
AFTERNOON IT IS WAS IT YOU KNOW
INCREDIBLY INFORMATIVE- IT'S
BEEN INCREDIBLY HELPFUL IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW WILDFIRES
HAVE IMPACTED OUR STATE- AND
ESPECIALLY HOW IT IMPACTS
AGRICULTURE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THIS YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE IS OBVIOUSLY GOING
TO DO OR NEED TO DO A LOT MORE.
WITH A LOT LESS NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO THE RESOURCES- THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE FUNDING-
BUT I BELIEVE THAT. WE CAN DO
IT THE SO LONG AS WE HAVE
EXPERTS WE HAVE RESEARCHERS
FARMERS WE HAVE FARMWORKERS-
THEY'RE ALL GONNA BE PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION. AND YOU KNOW
TACKLING THIS ISSUE IS NOT
GOING TO BE EASY. BUT CLEARLY-
WE MUST WORK TOGETHER IF WE
WANT TO MAKE A LASTING- AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY IMPACTFUL
PUBLIC POLICY- WE WILL TAKE
WHAT WE LEARNED THIS AFTERNOON
WE WILL CONTINUE TO REACH OUT
TO VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS- TO
CRAFT SOLUTIONS THAT WILL BRING
ALL OF US BACK TOGETHER. A TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS- AND SO WITH
THAT THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
MAKING THE TIME. AND I. HOPE
YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD HOLIDAY
SEASON AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU GUYS EARLY NEXT YEAR
FOR ACCESSION.